Hi, I'm Will Onnet from Spotless, I'm 31 years of age. I'm Jason. Hear me out. You know, when you were on the show, were the nerves- These are the questions, come on. I mean, were you happy or were you sad? Because you could get on the show. Hey guys, come on, let's not fight.
嗨，我是来自Spotless的Will Onnet，今年31岁。我是Jason。听我说。你知道，当你上节目的时候，那种紧张感——这些都是问题，拜托。我是说，你当时是开心还是难过？因为你本来可以上节目的。嘿伙计们，别吵了。
I'm Sean. I didn't know where I- I don't understand what you guys are coming for. Hi, I'm Dana Carvey and I'm on Smartless. Smart. Lies. Smart. Lies. Smart.
我是Sean。我不知道我——我不明白你们到底想干什么。嗨，我是Dana Carvey，我正在参加Smartless。Smart。Lies。Smart。Lies。Smart。
Lies. Smart. Lies. Smart. Lies. Sean, what was your meal last night? My meal last night was I had chicken salad sandwich and mac and cheese. Box mac and cheese.
Lies。Smart。Lies。Smart。Lies。Sean，你昨晚吃了什么？我昨晚吃的是鸡肉沙拉三明治和通心粉奶酪。盒装的通心粉奶酪。
You ended up at an 11-year-old's birthday party? What happened? Did the camp counselor just bring that over to you or was it set up at a- No, but you know, Scotty and I, we actually watched the Chargers Buffalo Bills game. And whenever the Buffalo Bills play, whenever they come on the screen, one of us will always go, Buffalo bell, I'll help you try to catch them, Carries. Oh man, that sounds like a fun house. What a fun house.
你最后竟然去参加了一个11岁小孩的生日派对？发生了什么？是露营辅导员带你去的，还是在某个地方安排的——不，但你知道，Scotty和我，我们其实看了闪电队对阵布法罗比尔队的比赛。每当布法罗比尔队比赛时，每当他们出现在屏幕上，我们其中一个人总会说，布法罗比尔，我会帮你抓住他们的，Carries。天哪，那听起来像个有趣的房子。真是个有趣的房子。
You guys have a lot of fun. Buffalo bell. The Wonder Truck, the Wonder Bread, they just come to your house, they just fuck the supermarket, they go straight to the house and just- They slow down, they throw the back open. They don't even stop. No, they don't even stop. Like the ice cream truck.
你们玩得很开心。布法罗比尔。神奇卡车，神奇面包，他们直接开到你家，管他什么超市，直接开到家门口然后——他们减速，把后门打开。他们甚至不停下来。不，他们甚至不停下来。就像冰淇淋车一样。
So the chicken salad sandwich, did you make the chicken salad? It was made, it was pre-made. Okay. From where? When you say it was made by what? The heavens? No, I bought it pre-made. Oh, I see, I see.
那么鸡肉沙拉三明治，鸡肉沙拉是你做的吗？那是做好的，是预先做好的。好吧。从哪儿来的？当你说是谁做的时候？天堂吗？不，我买的是预制好的。哦，我明白了，我明白了。
Like a tub of it. Yeah. I didn't know that CVS made chicken salad. Did you spoon it out on your Wonder Bread? CVS. CVS is like a pharmacy. Yeah. Oh, you think people don't know what CVS is?
就像一桶那种。对。我不知道CVS还做鸡肉沙拉。你是用勺子把它舀到你的神奇面包上的吗？CVS。CVS就像一家药店。对。哦，你以为人们不知道CVS是什么吗？
The mac and cheese, did that also- That came from a box. That came from a box. But I also had, what else did I have? I had brownies. When was the last time you put something in your face that didn't have preservatives in it? And let's keep it clean. I don't know.
那通心粉奶酪，也是——那是从盒子里拿出来的。那是从盒子里拿出来的。但我还吃了，我还吃了什么？我吃了布朗尼。你上次往嘴里塞没有防腐剂的东西是什么时候？咱们说点干净的。我不知道。
Oh, I had a salad. I had a little tiny Caesar salad with bread crumbs in it. You fucking stopped the presses. CVS has a salad, bro. Who's guest is it today? It's my guest. You know what? Let's get to our guest.
哦，我吃了个沙拉。我吃了一个带面包丁的小凯撒沙拉。你他妈的真是惊天动地。CVS有沙拉，兄弟。今天是谁的嘉宾？是我的嘉宾。你知道吗？咱们来聊聊我们的嘉宾吧。
Because our guest is way too funny to not be heard from at this point. Our guest, we often run into this problem. We start listing off their credits and then it's like just, it's too quick. I love how Will always freestyles these intros. Well, because I just try to keep it organic. I just want to be as freestyle and organic as this person is very funny. You have bullet points there that you'd like to hit? I do.
因为我们的嘉宾太有趣了，现在不听听他的声音简直说不过去。我们的嘉宾，我们经常遇到这个问题。我们开始列举他们的成就，然后就像，太快了。我喜欢Will总是即兴发挥这些开场白。嗯，因为我只是想保持自然。我只想像这个人一样即兴和自然，他非常有趣。你那里有想提到的要点吗？有的。
Okay. You might remember him from his role in Halloween 2. Sure. You might remember him from the film Tough Guys. Is this Jack O' Lantern? Do you remember Tough Guys? Tough Guys. Kirk Douglas.
好的。你可能还记得他在《月光光心慌慌2》中的角色。当然。你可能还记得他在电影《硬汉》中的表现。这是杰克南瓜灯吗？你记得《硬汉》吗？《硬汉》。柯克·道格拉斯。
No. Do you remember back in the 80s? Yeah. It's a big film. This guy, Sean, in that film. He then went on to, he's not religious, but he's been known to maybe keep track of people going when and where they go to church. He's trying to underplay this.
不。你还记得80年代吗？记得。那是一部大片。这家伙，Sean，在那部电影里。他后来，他虽然不信教，但他以关注人们何时何地去教堂而闻名。他试图淡化这一点。
He was never elected to office, but you might remember his George Bush. He's got a hilarious podcast with our hilarious friend, David Spade now. I love Dana Carvey. He's one of the funniest dudes of all time. I've never met him before. He's Mr. Dana Carvey. I love Dana Carvey. I'm Dana Carvey.
他从未当选公职，但你可能记得他的乔治·布什。他和我们搞笑的朋友David Spade现在有个搞笑的播客。我爱Dana Carvey。他是史上最有趣的人之一。我以前从没见过他。他是Dana Carvey先生。我爱Dana Carvey。我是Dana Carvey。
Whoa. Welcome. He's going to reveal himself. Oh my gosh. There he is. Oh, there he is. What are you doing, boys? What are you doing in Bennett's house?
哇。欢迎。他要现身了。天哪。他就在那儿。哦，他就在那儿。你们在干什么，伙计们？你们在Bennett家干什么？
Because I demanded it. What is it? Did you guys do a house swap today? Yeah. We did a house swap. I demanded to be upstairs. This is the first time we've ever done this. Dana is joining us from Bennett's place, which is amazing.
因为我要求的。是什么？你们今天换房子了吗？对。我们换了房子。我要求在楼上。这是我们第一次这样做。Dana是从Bennett家加入我们的，这太棒了。
This is crazy. You've got an incoming. I don't understand. Are you guys having a sleepover? There was a slumber party last night. I've never seen Jason this perplexed, even in Ozarks. I know. I have.
这太疯狂了。你们有客人来了。我不明白。你们在搞睡衣派对吗？昨晚有个睡衣派对。我从没见过Jason这么困惑，即使在《黑钱胜地》里也没有。我知道。我见过。
Dana, just put a book in front of him. You'll see the same look. Dana. Anyway, here they are. They're the spotless guys. They just woke up. They're a little bit sleepy. Can you believe it?
Dana，只要在他面前放本书。你会看到同样的表情。Dana。总之，他们在这儿。他们是Spotless的伙计们。他们刚醒。他们有点困。你敢相信吗？
Sean Hayes, Mr. Fun. You know, you got the voice over there. Will on that. And of course, Jason Bateman on the brains of the operation. That's right. You can tell by the glasses. I like that it's almost a regis. It almost sounded like reges.
Sean Hayes，趣味先生。你知道，你有那个配音。Will Onnet。当然，还有大脑担当Jason Bateman。没错。从眼镜就能看出来。我喜欢这听起来几乎像Regis。听起来几乎像Regis。
Old school reges. It was reges. You know, one time I remember you said something about, when you used to do reges years ago and you said, I remember this. I don't know why it stuck. You said, he's so uncool. He's cool.
老派的Regis。那是Regis。你知道，有一次我记得你说过，当你多年前做Regis的时候，你说，我记得这个。我不知道为什么它一直留在脑海里。你说，他太不酷了。他很酷。
Do you remember saying that? Totally. Like 30 years ago. It's always stuck with me. I always thought that was such a funny comment. And true. Well, it's Carson at it too. It's earnestness.
你记得说过那话吗？完全记得。就像30年前一样。它一直留在我的脑海里。我一直觉得那是一个非常有趣的评论。而且是真的。嗯，Carson也一样。那是真诚。
You know, that's, that's. Reges? My God. I remember when he was on AMLA out here in Los Angeles. This was like what, late 70s, early 80s. You know, I used to think it was the thing. So he, he was the, the father-in-law of, of a good friend of ours, Mike Shore. Mike Shore.
你知道，那是，那是。Regis？天哪。我记得当他在洛杉矶的AMLA时。那是大概什么，70年代末，80年代初。你知道，我过去常认为那是很棒的事。所以他，他是我们好朋友Mike Shore的岳父。Mike Shore。
And so I went over one time, Mike and his wife, J.J. were in New York. So they were staying with the, the Philbens and we went over to the apartment. Philbens. And we went in and it was like for, for coffee. And Regis came and he said, can I get you a coffee will? And he was, I was like, wow, this is real. He's this old fashioned show business.
所以有一次我去了那里，Mike和他的妻子J.J.在纽约。所以他们和Philben一家住在一起，我们去了那个公寓。Philben一家。我们进去了，就像是为了喝咖啡。Regis来了，他说，Will，我能给你倒杯咖啡吗？我当时想，哇，这是真的。他是这种老派的演艺圈人士。
He was, he was so positive. So I do it. I get to visit him. We actually interviewed William Shatner and I signed him off as Regis just spontaneously and he laughs so hard. Who doesn't like Bill Shatner? He's done it all. He's been everywhere.
他，他非常积极。所以我做了。我有机会拜访他。我们实际上采访了William Shatner，我自发地用Regis的方式结束了采访，他笑得很大声。谁不喜欢Bill Shatner？他什么都做过。他去过任何地方。
But now I do creep into Trump because that's how I started Trump with Regis. Robert Smigel and I talked about that. It's really Regis. Trump and Regis have a little bit of an overlap. But then you add in this, but we're going to a lot of places. We do it a lot of things and they go back and forth and Regis is here and Trump is there, but they're definitely overlapped. So it's just New York stuff, you know, it's, I want to entertain you guys.
但现在我确实会潜入特朗普，因为我就是从Regis开始模仿特朗普的。Robert Smigel和我谈过那个。那真的是Regis。特朗普和Regis有一点重叠。但后来你加上这个，但我们要去很多地方。我们做了很多事情，他们来回切换，Regis在这里，特朗普在那里，但他们绝对有重叠。所以这只是纽约的东西，你知道，我，我想娱乐你们。
I've been listening to your podcasts. You need to be entertained. You guys work hard. You are the person to do it. I love you used to do. I mentioned George Bush. So the first George Bush in, in you, you kind of deposited a virus into the vernacular of not going to do it, which has become a thing that like sometimes I'll almost
我一直在听你们的播客。你们需要被娱乐。你们工作很努力。你是做这件事的人。我喜欢你过去做的。我提到了乔治·布什。所以第一个乔治·布什，你，你有点像在语言习惯中植入了一种病毒，即“不打算做”，这已经成为了一种东西，有时我几乎会
like, dramatically. I can't stop saying it. Well, I don't know if that's what you guys have all your kind of inside jokes and catch phrases. And I love Sean's Hannibal Hector. Was it? Yeah. What do you have to ask?
像，戏剧性地。我停不下来。嗯，我不知道这是否就是你们所有的那种内部笑话和口头禅。我喜欢Sean的汉尼拔·莱克特。是吗？对。你有什么要问的？
Yeah. I did a movie with Anthony Hopkins once and we would entertain the crew. Cause he's like Sammy Davis Jr. He was an impressionist who became the world's greatest actor. Wow. And so he would do different, you know, I do James Cagney and I do Jimmy Stewart and then eventually to entertain the crew, you do Hannibal Hector and I would do Garth. I can smell Wayne on you.
对。我曾经和安东尼·霍普金斯拍过一部电影，我们会娱乐剧组。因为他就像小萨米·戴维斯。他是一个成为世界上最伟大演员的模仿者。哇。所以他会做不同的，你知道，我做詹姆斯·卡格尼，我做吉米·斯图尔特，然后最终为了娱乐剧组，你做汉尼拔·莱克特，我会做Garth。我能闻到你身上的Wayne味。
You know, that kind of thing. Get away big scary man. But as far as extenuating rhythms, I mean everyone does it. That's what I would do in high school. You know, so George Bush Sr. on the cue card, it would say not going to do it. Like four years before not going to do it. By your four it was like not any guy. And they went with it. I used to do, I used to do an impression of what it was not.
你知道，那种事。走开，大可怕的人。但就延伸节奏而言，我的意思是每个人都这么做。这就是我在高中时会做的。你知道，所以老乔治·布什在提示卡上，会写着“不打算做”。就像在“不打算做”之前四年。到第四年就像“不打算做任何家伙”。他们就这么做了。我过去常做，我过去常模仿那不是什么。
It was you doing George W Bush, but it was, it was a Jimmy. What's his name? Oh, you know, not gonna do it. You know, Jimmy Stewart. Jimmy Stewart doing an impression of you doing George Bush. That's all right. With my friend Giles. I used to do it all the time.
那是你模仿乔治·W·布什，但那是，那是吉米。他叫什么名字？哦，你知道，不打算做。你知道，吉米·斯图尔特。吉米·斯图尔特模仿你模仿乔治·布什。没关系。和我朋友Giles一起。我过去常一直做。
I got, nah, I got to do it. I don't know why. And I used to call it, this is Jimmy Stewart doing Dana doing things. I smuggled a cassette tape recorder in the mid seventies into the Circle Star Theater near San Francisco so I could tape Rich Little's act because there was no YouTube. And from taping that and listening, I just took his Jimmy Stewart. And it's somebody that you just, you just, you just sort of want to sneak up on. And the thing I like about Jimmy Stewart is then I get mad.
我得，不，我得做。我不知道为什么。我过去常叫它，这是吉米·斯图尔特模仿Dana做事情。我在70年代中期把一台卡式录音机偷运进旧金山附近的Circle Star剧院，这样我就可以录下Rich Little的表演，因为那时没有YouTube。通过录下那个并听，我只是拿走了他的吉米·斯图尔特。这是你只是，你只是，你只是想悄悄接近的人。我喜欢吉米·斯图尔特的一点是，然后我会生气。
I like the angry Jimmy Stewart. Well, you know what you were doing, didn't you? Well, you know, I'm not going to play this game anymore. And so that became the reason I'm a comedian because I sucked so bad. But Jimmy Stewart as a waiter never failed in a biker bar. It occurs to me that Jimmy Stewart kind of sounds like Mason Adams. He used to do smockers. When you get smockers, you get so much smockers.
我喜欢愤怒的吉米·斯图尔特。嗯，你知道你在做什么，不是吗？嗯，你知道，我不会再玩这个游戏了。所以这就成了我成为喜剧演员的原因，因为我太烂了。但吉米·斯图尔特作为服务员在摩托车酒吧里从未失败过。我突然想到吉米·斯图尔特听起来有点像Mason Adams。他过去常做Smockers。当你得到Smockers时，你会得到这么多Smockers。
Are you a secret impressionist? I'm not at all. I'm not at all, but that's just a fun voice to do. I don't even know who it is, but I'm your guest today. Hey, hey, it's almost Owen Wilson, isn't it? We could go to Argentina and go surfing if you want, you know, that'd be fun. I told Owen I would never do his impression on TV, but I'm on a podcast. Sorry, Sean, you're next.
你是秘密模仿者吗？我根本不是。我根本不是，但这只是一个有趣的嗓音。我甚至不知道那是谁，但我今天是你嘉宾。嘿，嘿，这几乎是欧文·威尔逊，不是吗？如果你想的话，我们可以去阿根廷冲浪，你知道，那会很有趣。我告诉欧文我永远不会在电视上模仿他，但我现在在播客上。抱歉，Sean，下一个是你。
Oh, no, I was just going to say. As I say, Jason and Will actually do like really great accents. And like I can't do as good of accents as those because so I bet you guys do impressions. I've just never heard. Well, I don't know. I do some accents good. How are you? What's your favorite easiest accent to do?
哦，不，我只是想说。正如我所说，Jason和Will实际上做非常棒的口音。而且我做不出像他们那样好的口音，因为所以我敢打赌你们做模仿。我只是从来没听过。嗯，我不知道。我做一些口音很好。你好吗？你最喜欢、最容易做的口音是什么？
Me? Any of you guys. Jason whips out a British one like nobody can do it. And also like, and also. There's so many flavors of British ones. You want to be like, yeah, you can go like, I found myself talking. I'm not joking this morning going because I was watching Tottenham Arsenal in the North London Derby. And I was going, not today, my son, not today.
我？你们中的任何一个。Jason拿出一个英国口音，没人能做到。而且，而且。英国口音有很多种味道。你想成为，是的，你可以去，我发现自己说话。我没开玩笑，今天早上因为我在看北伦敦德比托特纳姆对阿森纳。我当时在说，今天不行，我的儿子，今天不行。
And I'm like, there's nobody here but my dog. The kids are up at their moms. I was like, what am I doing? We've been watching Gary Oldman. We mean me and my wife on slow horses. Oh, yeah. And then by the end of it, I'm like, you're a bunch of lazy losers. And you don't know what the fuck you're doing.
我当时想，这里除了我的狗没人。孩子们在他们妈妈那里。我当时想，我在做什么？我们一直在看加里·奥德曼。我是说我和我妻子在看《流人》。哦，是的。然后到最后，我就像，你们这群懒惰的失败者。你们根本不知道自己在做什么。
It's kind of a, it's sort of a, it's a light version of Michael Cain. Yeah. But I want to say before, which is, if you want to do hip, you go down to stairs. You stop bloody up here and then you walk it right down to stage. Oh God. Would Steve Coogan and Rob Briden do that in the, what was the name of the film that they do? Oh, those guys. The trip.
这有点，这是一种，这是迈克尔·凯恩的轻量版。是的。但我想在之前说的是，如果你想做时髦，你就下楼梯。你停止在这里血腥，然后你直接走下舞台。哦天哪。Steve Coogan和Rob Brydon会在那个，他们拍的电影叫什么名字？哦，那些家伙。《旅途》。
Yeah, the trip. Yeah, the trip. I learned that impression. I rarely try and actively go, I got to do that guy. It was from Steve Coogan's impression and I actually practice it. Then I did a prank phone call to JJ Abrams. Oh yeah. Really?
是的，《旅途》。是的，《旅途》。我学会了那个模仿。我很少尝试并主动去，我必须做那个家伙。那是来自Steve Coogan的模仿，我实际上练习了它。然后我给J.J.艾布拉姆斯打了个恶作剧电话。哦，是的。真的吗？
This is my cocaine here. I heard you make it. I want to do spaceship shows. And I'd like to put my hat in the ring. I know I'm a bit longer than two, but maybe this old dinosaur's got one lap left to run. What's that process like with you? You want to take on a new impression. You want to see how close you are to something that you would like.
这是我的可卡因。我听说你做了。我想做太空秀。我想把我的帽子扔进戒指里。我知道我比二长一点，但也许这只老恐龙还有一圈要跑。那个过程对你来说是什么样的？你想尝试一个新的模仿。你想看看你离你想要的东西有多近。
Where are you? Are you in the bathroom in front of a mirror or are you just in the car because you just need to hear it. You don't need to see it. If I'm alone at home or in a car or many times I'll be practicing when I'm hiking. Oh really? Sure. And I'm like, oh dad, now what?
你在哪儿？你在浴室镜子前，还是你在车里，因为你只需要听到它。你不需要看到它。如果我独自在家或在车里，或者很多时候我会在徒步旅行时练习。哦，真的吗？当然。我当时想，哦爸爸，现在怎么了？
Yeah, bloody saying. Then I see a hiker and I have to go. Yes, honey. I'm really, I'll be home in a minute. I have to actually cover for my voices. I like the idea that there's somebody in West LA who went for a hike and they didn't see anybody. They were like, I think I heard Michael Cain on the hike today.
是的，血腥的说。然后我看到一个徒步旅行者，我不得不去。是的，亲爱的。我真的，我一会儿就回家。我不得不为我的声音打掩护。我喜欢西洛杉矶有人去徒步旅行，他们没看到任何人。他们当时想，我想我今天在徒步旅行时听到了迈克尔·凯恩。
Or the church lay. I want to say, connect six degrees separation. So I was on vacation. They told me to send an email to Paul McCartney in case you would go on. And I ended up interviewing Paul McCartney from the four seasons in Jackson Hole, Wyoming, because I was there with my family. And I listened to you guys talking to Paul because I was looking at where is he on a podcast.
或者教堂女士。我想说，连接六度分隔。所以我当时在度假。他们告诉我给保罗·麦卡特尼发封邮件，以防你会去。我最终在怀俄明州杰克逊霍尔的四季酒店采访了保罗·麦卡特尼，因为我和家人在那里。我听了你们和保罗的谈话，因为我在看他在播客上在哪儿。
So I listened to your podcast to try to get a sense of how to navigate that because it's Paul McCartney. And what you found was there couldn't be a nicer, more approachable fella. Right? I mean, like, I was so blown away by how kind he was. Here is like, you guys have to be Beetle fans in your age group, right? Oh, Sean, to the podcast. I didn't think he wanted to talk about the Beatles, especially, you know, but then after
所以我听了你们的播客，试图了解如何处理这个问题，因为那是保罗·麦卡特尼。你发现没有比他更友善、更平易近人的家伙了。对吧？我的意思是，我被他的善良震撼了。这里就像，你们必须是你们年龄段的披头士粉丝，对吧？哦，Sean，去播客。我没想到他想谈论披头士，特别是，你知道，但在那之后
a while of going around and around, I just brought up, get back the documentary. Right. Then he lit up. And then for all of us, the last forensic part of the Beatles is who did what? Because you know, it's kind of like no reply is John Lennon's song, but did Paul write the middle eight, you know? So at one point I took a chance. I said, did John ever thank you for your bass lines?
绕来绕去一段时间后，我只是提到了《Get Back》纪录片。对。然后他亮了起来。然后对我们所有人来说，披头士最后法医部分是谁做了什么？因为你知道，这有点像《No Reply》是约翰·列侬的歌，但保罗写了中间八小节吗，你知道？所以有一次我冒了个险。我说，约翰有没有感谢过你的低音线条？
Right. And that lit him up, you know? Yeah. Well, I was the bass player. You know, normally the bass player is like the fat guy. He's the fat guy. You know, and I was the plonk, plonk, plonk, plonk, plonk. And I go, I go, you got a lot better.
对。那让他亮了起来，你知道？是的。嗯，我是贝斯手。你知道，通常贝斯手就像胖子。他是胖子。你知道，我是那个咚、咚、咚、咚、咚。我说，我说，你变得好多了。
Was she so heavy and dear prunes? Well, I go, I just got up the keyboard. There's never been a more humble genius in his vernacular ever. You got for a plonk, me and John, eyeball to eyeball. I was just plonking, we're plonking. Next thing you know, we had the white album. Did you do, did you do him to him at all too or no? I did.
她在《Dear Prudence》里那么重吗？嗯，我说，我刚起来键盘。他的语言中从来没有比这更谦逊的天才。你得到了一个咚，我和约翰，眼对眼。我只是在咚，我们在咚。接下来你知道，我们有了《白色专辑》。你对他做过他吗，还是没有？我做了。
I did a little bit, but I was so insimidated. You know, you just remind me, I think that the accent that you were asking before and not to go back, but it just, you know, I love accents, which was, which is, I used to always go Jackie Stewart and I used to get into it. It's an absolutely brutal day for multi car racing. That's great. That would get me into it. So this past fall, these guys know I've been doing a lot of stuff with Formula One
我做了一点，但我太胆怯了。你知道，你只是提醒我，我想你之前问的那个口音，不是要回去，但它只是，你知道，我喜欢口音，也就是，我过去常一直做杰基·斯图尔特，我过去常进入它。对于多车比赛来说，这是绝对残酷的一天。那太棒了。那会让我进入状态。所以去年秋天，这些家伙知道我一直在做很多关于一级方程式的事情
and I'm in Singapore at the Formula One race. And I see, and this guy goes, do you want to meet Jackie Stewart? I go, yeah. And we go up where I meet him and he's walking and he looks fantastic. And I go, you know, you're using saying my, you know, my name is Jackie Stewart. It's a brutal day. I go, that's how I would get into doing my Scottish accent. And he goes, Oh, is that right?
我在新加坡一级方程式比赛。我看到，这个家伙说，你想见杰基·斯图尔特吗？我说，想。我们上去见到他，他正在走，他看起来棒极了。我说，你知道，你一直在说我的，你知道，我的名字是杰基·斯图尔特。这是残酷的一天。我说，那就是我进入苏格兰口音的方式。他说，哦，是吗？
And that was it. And he kept walking. He was like, why are you stopping me? I'm Scottish, but that wouldn't kind of, I tilt away from that a lot. I can do Irish pretty good, but probably too grandiose. I've got a lot of Irish relatives. Wait, wait, what's the difference between Scottish and Irish? If you were to say, a tough day for racing.
那就是全部。他继续走。他就像，你为什么要拦住我？我是苏格兰人，但这不会，我经常偏离那个。我能做得很好，但可能太宏大了。我有很多爱尔兰亲戚。等等，等等，苏格兰和爱尔兰有什么区别？如果你要说，比赛残酷的一天。
No, I'm just, what would be the sound difference between Scottish and Irish? Tough day for racing. Well, an Irish might say, well, it's a tough, a tough day for racing. Yeah, it's a little more little tea. It's a little more little tea and not as hard on that. Paul has a lot of Irish relatives because of the, the little teen Liverpool accent, which always sounds like you're asking a question. Did you go to the store?
不，我只是，苏格兰和爱尔兰的声音区别是什么？比赛残酷的一天。嗯，爱尔兰人可能会说，嗯，这是一个残酷的，残酷的比赛日。是的，它有点更多小T。它有点更多小T，在那个上面没那么硬。保罗有很多爱尔兰亲戚，因为那个，利物浦口音的小T，听起来总是像你在问一个问题。你去商店了吗？
Like Canadians. I did go to the store. Well, did you go? So many Irish moved across to Liverpool and if you'll even Manchester, if you look at the Gallagher brothers from, from Oasis, and then north of that is a town called Blackpool, which is a, this is a good interesting place. It's a seaside town and resort town, Blackpool.
像加拿大人。我确实去了商店。嗯，你去了吗？这么多爱尔兰人搬到了利物浦，如果你甚至看曼彻斯特，如果你看来自绿洲乐队的加拉格尔兄弟，在那北边是一个叫布莱克浦的城镇，这是一个，这是一个很好的有趣的地方。这是一个海滨城镇和度假小镇，布莱克浦。
Next to the water, huh? Great. Dublin in Irish means Blackpool. It's the same thing. How about that? A lot of Irish people. I can trim all this. I thought you guys might want to read some,
靠近水边，哈？太棒了。都柏林在爱尔兰语中意味着布莱克浦。是一回事。那怎么样？很多爱尔兰人。我可以修剪所有这些。我以为你们可能想读一些，
you don't need to read shit because you've got me as a friend. Thanks for that, Will. I love the Irish, my wife's Irish relatives are mothers from Dublin. She's 91 and the relatives came over and they're so humble. As you know, there's just like, you go to a grocery store and it's like bread. Hey, there's like three items. I took them to a supermarket for the first time. My wife's aunt and uncle and they go, look at all the yogurt.
你不需要读狗屎，因为你有我这个朋友。谢谢你，Will。我爱爱尔兰人，我妻子的爱尔兰亲戚是来自都柏林的母亲。她91岁了，亲戚们过来了，他们太谦虚了。如你所知，就像，你去杂货店，就像面包。嘿，就像三样东西。我第一次带他们去超市。我妻子的阿姨和叔叔，他们说，看所有的酸奶。
They go, why do you need so many cereals? I didn't have any response to that. It's free market capitalism. I have no idea why we need 900 times. Wait. So Dana, walk me through you. So you do all this. You mentioned that you go in and you recorded Rich Little.
他们说，你为什么需要这么多麦片？我对此没有任何回应。这是自由市场资本主义。我不知道为什么我们需要900次。等等。所以Dana，带我走过你。所以你做所有这些。你提到你进去并录制了Rich Little。
What was the thing? How did you go and make? I always like to understand when people go and make the jump from being a super fan or somebody who's interested, who has the talent for listening to it, to actually getting paid for what they do. What was that jump for you? Was it doing impressions or is it doing standup or was it a combo?
那是什么东西？你是怎么去做的？我总是喜欢理解当人们去并从超级粉丝或对它感兴趣、有听力天赋的人跳跃到真正为他们所做的事情获得报酬时。那个跳跃对你来说是什么？是做模仿还是做单口相声，还是组合？
Both. I didn't lean on the impressions. I did them, but I did a lot of other stuff too. But I was so, it really seemed like trying to be Neil Armstrong for someone from my household, five kids. Dad was a high school teacher, 1,500 square feet, one bathroom that I would be on television. And so that upended me a little bit.
两者都有。我没有依赖模仿。我做了它们，但我还做了很多其他事情。但我太，这真的看起来像是试图成为尼尔·阿姆斯特朗，对于我家里的某个人，五个孩子。爸爸是高中老师，1500平方英尺，一个浴室，我会上电视。所以那让我有点颠覆。
I did a lot of things. I was probably a waste of time, but Hollywood started hiring me just as a cute, nice guy. You had roles in movies and you were doing stuff before you got an SNL. They didn't care for me to be funny. I was doing standup in the side, but they offered me one of the boys with Mickey Rooney. And so I did it.
我做了很多事情。我可能是在浪费时间，但好莱坞开始雇佣我，只是作为一个可爱、好的人。你在电影里有角色，你在SNL之前就在做事情。他们不在乎我是否有趣。我在旁边做单口相声，但他们给了我米基·鲁尼的《男孩之一》。所以我做了。
It was $7,500 a week. I was like pennies from heaven. Was it Meg Ryan in that? Meg Ryan was in six episodes, played my girlfriend, I believe, Scatman and of course. Was it Megan back then? Yeah, so you caught that. Was it?
那是每周7500美元。我当时就像来自天堂的便士。梅格·瑞恩在里面吗？梅格·瑞恩在六集里，扮演我的女朋友，我相信，当然还有Scatman。那是当时的Megan吗？是的，所以你抓住了那个。是吗？
It was Megan. Well, Megsy by the end. It's kind of like Anthony Hopkins. It was Anthony Tony and then it was Hoppy by the time we ended. You go Meg Ryan, you go Megan, you go Mickey Rooney. He's like Michael Rooney. Yeah, sure. They were all in it.
那是Megan。嗯，到最后是Megsy。这有点像安东尼·霍普金斯。那是安东尼·托尼，然后当我们结束时是Hoppy。你走梅格·瑞恩，你走Megan，你走米基·鲁尼。他就像迈克尔·鲁尼。是的，当然。他们都在里面。
Mickey's macaroni. Mickey's everything. Mickey was the craziest person I ever met and had a 35 revolver in his jacket. Wait, what? A 38 and he would wave it around. They're not going to get me. Yes, he had a loaded gun.
米基的通心粉。米基的一切。米基是我见过最疯狂的人，外套里有一把35左轮手枪。等等，什么？一把38，他会挥舞它。他们不会抓住我。是的，他有一把装满子弹的枪。
He goes, this script is kaka. And then he would throw it across. No, you've heard stories about Mickey Rooney, haven't you? No. I mean, not really. You're outing him right now. I'm young. You know who he was, right?
他说，这个剧本是垃圾。然后他会把它扔过去。不，你听说过关于米基·鲁尼的故事，不是吗？不。我的意思是，不是真的。你现在在揭露他。我还年轻。你知道他是谁，对吧？
Yeah, of course. So if he said this once, he said it a thousand times, literally every day. I was just like this. We did it on SNL and I was writing it with Bonnie and Terry Turner and I just said what Mickey said in that incredible laughs. I didn't write it. I said, I was the number one star in the world.
是的，当然。所以如果他说了这个一次，他说了它一千次，字面上每天。我当时就像这样。我们在SNL上做了它，我和Bonnie和Terry Turner一起写它，我只是说了米基在那些不可思议的笑声中说的话。我没写它。我说，我是世界上第一大明星。
Hear me? Bang. The world. And that's exactly the way he said it a thousand times. Number one star in the world. Bang. Hear me? The world.
听到了吗？砰。世界。那正是他说了那一千次的方式。世界上第一大明星。砰。听到了吗？世界。
What is that sound supposed to be? What's he doing? I don't know. But he was just, he had a gun, Scatman on stone. He thought I was gay. Sure. And I was there with Nathan Lane. So we had to do a three's company thing.
那个声音应该是为了什么？他在做什么？我不知道。但他只是，他有一把枪，Scatman喝醉了。他以为我是同性恋。当然。我和Nathan Lane在那里。所以我们不得不做《三人行》的事情。
Oh, there you go. Where he had his arm around Nathan. He looked at me and said, I'm just glad we like girls. What? I was so huge. Wait, what a fucking cast. So it was you, Nathan Lane, Meg Ryan and Mickey Rooney. And Scatman Carruthers.
哦，给你。他搂着Nathan。他看着我说，我很高兴我们喜欢女孩。什么？我太巨大了。等等，什么他妈的演员阵容。所以是你，Nathan Lane，梅格·瑞恩和米基·鲁尼。还有Scatman Carruthers。
Who just was stoned. The nicest guy I've ever met. But he was just high all day. And my brother came to visit me and he gave us some pot. And it was terrible. So the next trip, I brought him a lid of Santa Cruz, Colombian pot. Can you believe this?
他只是喝醉了。我见过最友善的家伙。但他整天都很高。我哥哥来看我，他给了我们一些大麻。那太糟糕了。所以下一次旅行，我给他带了一盖子圣克鲁斯，哥伦比亚大麻。你能相信吗？
This is like 1981. Classic blend. Next morning in the elevator, he says, the music was good. How'd I get a pound? So after the show was, yeah. Didn't want to mess around with an ounce. No. It was called music.
这就像1981年。经典混合。第二天早上在电梯里，他说，音乐很好。我怎么得到一磅？所以节目结束后，是的。不想弄乱一盎司。不。它叫音乐。
It was a little bit. And he had a clear bottle full of vitamins. And he would walk back and forth across the sound stage, chugging them going, I'm going to a hundred. I'm going to a hundred. And he would chug the vitamins. After the show, my brother and I got him a whole bag. We didn't smoke much weed after this.
它有一点。他有一个装满维生素的透明瓶子。他会在音响舞台上来回走动，大口喝着它们说，我要去一百。我要去一百。然后他会大口喝维生素。节目结束后，我和我哥哥给他弄了一整袋。我们之后没抽多少大麻。
But anyway, a bag of Santa Cruz pot. Giant and brought it to Van Nuys, brought it to his house. And he played the ukulele for us for hours. No way. What's this project called? I got to see this. One of the boys. One of the boys.
但无论如何，一袋圣克鲁斯大麻。巨大的，带到了Van Nuys，带到了他家。他为我们弹了几个小时的尤克里里。没门。这个项目叫什么？我得看看这个。《男孩之一》。《男孩之一》。
Looking up online. One of the boys. The craziest. I wore a sweater. I was the straight man. Literally. Mickey. We would do impressions together too.
在网上查。One of the boys。最疯狂的。我穿了一件毛衣。我是直男。字面上。米基。我们也一起做模仿。
He was an impressionist, but he did have a 38 revolver. And he said, before I got this big break, I was going to go to Sacramento to the prison there. There's a serial killer, Juan Corona. I was going to come in as a visitor. I was going to bring my 38. I was going to say, you know, I am, I'm Mickey Rooney. And I was going to plug him full of holes.
他是一个模仿者，但他确实有一把38左轮手枪。他说，在我得到这个大突破之前，我要去萨克拉门托的监狱。那里有一个连环杀手，Juan Corona。我要以访客身份进来。我要带上我的38。我要说，你知道，我是，我是米基·鲁尼。我要把他打满洞。
These are verbatim quotes. I'm going to play in his favorite thing I've ever told him. These are verbatim quotes from Mickey Rooney. And he's one of those old guys who would talk till he ran out of breath. And everything was a non sequitur. Julie Garland never owned a car. Pumped her so full of drugs, it killed her. How long has Robert Redford been in the business?
这些是逐字引语。我要播放我告诉过他最喜欢的事情。这些是来自米基·鲁尼的逐字引语。他是那种会一直说到没气的老家伙之一。一切都是不合逻辑的。朱莉·加兰从未拥有过车。给她泵了这么多毒品，杀了她。罗伯特·雷德福在这一行多久了？
Ten years? I've been in the business. It's like three weeks before his birth. I've been in the business 61 years. He's the greatest character I've ever met. By far. Really, really holding on to his past. Oh, yeah.
十年？我在这一行。就像他出生前三周。我在这一行61年了。他是我见过最伟大的角色。到目前为止。真的，真的坚持他的过去。哦，是的。
He was like, I called up Warner Brothers in 1955. I said, this is Mickey Rooney. I need a job. They hung up on me. And then he would wander off. And he had a new show, a new thing every day. Yeah. And we will be right back.
他就像，我1955年给华纳兄弟打电话。我说，这是米基·鲁尼。我需要一份工作。他们挂断了我的电话。然后他会走开。他每天都有一个新节目，一个新东西。是的。我们马上回来。
SmartList is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, to be my best self, I just feel like if I, if I can talk to somebody, open up to somebody, let them know what's going on inside of me. They might give you feedback. They might not, but at least you're talking it all through. And that's one of the things that BetterHelp can really help with. When you're at your best, you can do great things.
SmartList由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，为了成为最好的自己，我只是觉得如果我，如果我能和某人交谈，向某人敞开心扉，让他们知道我内心发生了什么。他们可能会给你反馈。他们可能不会，但至少你在谈论它。这就是BetterHelp真正能提供帮助的事情之一。当你处于最佳状态时，你可以做伟大的事情。
But sometimes life gets you bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed or like you're not showing up in the way that you want to. Working with a therapist can help you get closer to the best version of you. Because when you feel empowered, you're more prepared to take on everything life throws at you. I mean, I know that I've definitely benefited from therapy from just, sometimes it's a therapist, sometimes it's a best friend, sometimes it's a partner, sometimes it's,
但有时生活会让你陷入困境，你可能会感到不知所措，或者觉得你没有以你想要的方式出现。与治疗师合作可以帮助你更接近最好的自己。因为当你感到被授权时，你更有准备去应对生活抛给你的一切。我的意思是，我知道我绝对从治疗中受益，有时是治疗师，有时是最好的朋友，有时是伴侣，有时是，
but look, you need that, that person to bounce stuff on. If you're thinking about giving therapy a try, BetterHelp is a great option. Just give it a shot. It's convenient, it's flexible, it's affordable, and it's entirely online. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapist anytime if that is no longer a good match for you for no additional charge.
但看，你需要那个人来反弹东西。如果你正在考虑尝试治疗，BetterHelp是一个很好的选择。试一试。它很方便，很灵活，很实惠，而且完全在线。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持牌治疗师匹配，如果那不再是好的匹配，可以随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。
If you want to live a more empowered life, therapy can get you there. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp.com slash smartlist. So, betterhelp.com slash smartlist. Smartlist is brought to you in part by Viori Clothing, a new perspective on performance apparel.
如果你想过更被授权的生活，治疗可以让你到达那里。今天访问betterhelp.com/smartlist以获得首月10%的折扣。那是betterhelp.com/smartlist。所以，betterhelp.com/smartlist。Smartlist部分由Viori Clothing带给您，这是对性能服装的新视角。
What do I say? Just that I haven't said already about this incredible product, that it's really versatile. It can be used for just about any activity. I think I've covered that before. You can be running or training or swimming or yoga, but also great for lounging or just running weekend errands. I feel like a bit of a broken record about how great this stuff is,
我该说什么？只是我还没有说过关于这个不可思议的产品，它真的很通用。它可以用于几乎任何活动。我想我之前已经涵盖了这一点。你可以跑步或训练或游泳或瑜伽，但也非常适合休息或只是跑周末差事。我觉得自己像个坏掉的唱片，关于这些东西有多棒，
and I'm a fan because of this stuff I wear. I have these Viori stretchy, sort of, you know, weekend-y lounge pants that I adore, and when I couldn't find them the other day, I flipped out. I was flipping out, I was going through drawer, I was like, where are those? I need to have them. That's how much I enjoy it. You know, it's a really good marker of something that's great, is that you put it on and you feel simultaneously like it's new
我是粉丝，因为我穿这些东西。我有这些Viori弹性的，某种，你知道，周末休闲裤，我崇拜它们，当我不久前找不到它们时，我崩溃了。我崩溃了，我翻遍了抽屉，我当时想，那些在哪儿？我需要拥有它们。这就是我有多喜欢它。你知道，这是一个非常好的标志，说明某样东西很棒，就是你穿上它，你同时觉得它既是新的
and also that you've always had it in the best way, because it feels comfortable. Viori is an investment in your happiness. So, for our listener, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com slash smartlist. That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smartlist. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase,
而且你一直以最好的方式拥有它，因为它感觉很舒服。Viori是对你幸福的投资。所以，对于我们的听众，他们提供首购20%的折扣。在Viori.com/smartlist上为自己买一些地球上最舒适和通用的衣服。那是V-U-O-R-I点com斜杠smartlist。你不仅会收到首购20%的折扣，
but enjoy free shipping on any U.S. orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash smartlist and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. Thanks to ZipRecruiter for their support. Are you hiring? What type of role are you hiring for? Maybe you need to hire somebody to wear many hats, which can be challenging. Or you might have a simple position to fill,
而且享受任何超过75美元的美国订单免费送货和免费退货。去Viori.com/smartlist，发现Viori服装的多功能性。感谢ZipRecruiter的支持。你在招聘吗？你正在招聘什么类型的角色？也许你需要雇佣某人戴很多帽子，这可能具有挑战性。或者你可能有一个简单的职位要填补，
but it's taking forever to find someone who's a great fit for your company. So, whether you need to hire a civil engineer in New York, or a pediatric nurse in Nebraska, or an attorney in Colorado, or even a mascot in Missouri, ZipRecruiter can help you find quality candidates fast. And now you can try it for free at ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist. From accountant to zoologist and everything in between, ZipRecruiter's matching technology finds people with the right experience for your job
但找到一个非常适合你公司的人需要永远。所以，无论你需要雇佣纽约的土木工程师，还是内布拉斯加州的儿科护士，还是科罗拉多州的律师，甚至是密苏里州的吉祥物，ZipRecruiter都能帮助你快速找到高质量的候选人。现在你可以在ZipRecruiter.com/smartlist免费试用。从会计师到动物学家以及其间的一切，ZipRecruiter的匹配技术找到具有适合你工作经验的人
and presents them to you. Then you can invite your top choices to apply. What? It's so effective that four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Is that sinking in? Try it now for free at this exclusive web address.
并把他们呈现给你。然后你可以邀请你的首选申请。什么？它非常有效，以至于在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的五分之四的雇主在第一天内就得到了高质量的候选人。那沉下去了吗？现在在这个独家网址免费试用。
ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist. Once again, that is ZipRecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S. ZipRecruiter.com slash smartlist. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. And now, back to the show. Wait, Dana. Yes. When I was in high school, Mike Myers was on our show,
ZipRecruiter.com/smartlist。再一次，那是ZipRecruiter.com/S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S。ZipRecruiter.com/smartlist。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在，回到节目。等等，Dana。是的。当我在高中时，Mike Myers在我们的节目上，
and I said the same thing to him. I said, when I was in high school, you were God to me and God to everybody who was into comedy and sketch and just everything. I remember going to school on a Monday and everybody in high school would imitate the church lady and every single character you guys ever did in Wayne's World, whatever the characters were.
我对他说同样的话。我说，当我在高中时，你是我的上帝，也是所有喜欢喜剧和素描以及一切的人的上帝。我记得周一去学校，高中里的每个人都会模仿教堂女士和你们在《韦恩的世界》中做过的每一个角色，无论那些角色是什么。
And I always wondered after your incredible stint on SNL, I missed you. I missed seeing those. What happened to me? No, no, no. I mean, I've seen you. I saw you pop up in a bunch of stuff. But just as far as being a king of sketch comedy,
我一直想知道在你不可思议的SNL之后，我想念你。我想念看到那些。我怎么了？不，不，不。我的意思是，我见过你。我看到你在很多东西里出现。但就作为素描喜剧之王而言，
it's almost like, and I know you had a couple other spin-off kind of sketch comedy shows, but do you miss it at all still today? Because you're really one of the all-time greats. Thank you. Yeah, without a doubt. I mean, you got me to vote for Ross Perot. This is the first vote I ever cast.
这几乎就像，我知道你还有几个其他衍生类的素描喜剧节目，但你今天还想念它吗？因为你真的是史上最伟大的人之一。谢谢。是的，毫无疑问。我的意思是，你让我投票给Ross Perot。这是我投下的第一张票。
Ross Perot was a gift from heaven. That was my Sarah Palin for Tina Fey. Lord Michael said, there's someone running to Texas Billionaries running for president. We have some tape. Why don't you go down the hall and see if there's anything there? I turn it on. The ears are sticking out.
Ross Perot是来自天堂的礼物。那是我的Tina Fey的Sarah Palin。Lord Michael说，有一个德克萨斯亿万富翁在竞选总统。我们有一些磁带。你为什么不顺着大厅走，看看那里有什么？我打开它。耳朵伸出来了。
Can I finish? James Brown is already there. Can I finish one time? Or are you going to talk over me? Can I finish one time? Here's the deal. You can't put a porcupine in a barn, light it on fire, and expect to make licorice.
我能说完吗？James Brown已经在那里了。我能说完一次吗？还是你要跟我说话？我能说完一次吗？这就是交易。你不能把豪猪放在谷仓里，点火，并期望做甘草。
What? That was the gift. George Bush was worked. That was like... But still Hartman did Stockdale, right? Oh, yeah. When he tried to ditch him in the woods, you know, we were...
什么？那是礼物。乔治·布什被工作了。那就像……但Hartman仍然做了Stockdale，对吧？哦，是的。当他试图在树林里甩掉他时，你知道，我们是……
Stockdale was... I was driving as Ross, and I wanted to ditch him after his debate performance. Where are we going? Where am I? Phil could do anything. God rest his soul. I remember Phil used to do in that same election cycle,
Stockdale是……我开车作为Ross，我想在他辩论表现后甩掉他。我们要去哪儿？我在哪儿？Phil可以做任何事。上帝保佑他的灵魂。我记得Phil过去常在同一个选举周期做，
92, Phil was doing Clinton, and he would do the thing, and he'd come in, and he'd come into a McDonald's on a jog, and he starts making analogies and stealing people's food to make his analogy. Like, if I take a bite of this, and he's... And the whole thing was, he just wanted to eat everybody's McDonald's.
92年，Phil在做克林顿，他会做那件事，他会进来，他会慢跑进麦当劳，他开始做类比并偷人们的食物来做他的类比。就像，如果我咬一口这个，他就是……整个事情是，他只是想吃掉每个人的麦当劳。
Yes. Phil could do anything. I mean, I swear to God. I mean, you guys... I echo what Sean says. You guys were up there for me, too. I looked at... You guys were at such heights that I thought, I could never get anywhere near that.
是的。Phil可以做任何事。我的意思是，我向上帝发誓。我的意思是，你们……我呼应Sean说的话。你们对我来说也在那里。我看着……你们处于如此高度，以至于我想，我永远无法接近那个。
You guys are so incredible at what you do. I still look up to what you guys do, because you guys did it in this way. This is way before YouTube, and you could have control over it and do all this kind of shit. Like, you guys were doing it live on SNL in a way, and stuff that nobody else was doing.
你们在你们所做的事情上是如此不可思议。我仍然仰望你们所做的事情，因为你们以这种方式做到了。这远在YouTube之前，你可以控制它并做所有这些狗屎。就像，你们在SNL上现场直播，以一种没人做的方式，以及其他人没做的事情。
There's so much derivative shit that came out of that kind of era. Well, it might be. I mean, you guys have had all these weird things happen. Like, I had auditioned for the show twice. It just didn't get it. Al Franken saw me in San Francisco. I followed Kenison at the comedy store at midnight,
那个时代衍生出了太多垃圾。嗯，也许吧。我是说，你们经历过各种奇怪的事情。比如，我为那个节目试镜了两次。就是没选上。阿尔·弗兰肯在旧金山看到了我。午夜时分，我在喜剧商店接在肯尼森后面表演，
Sam Kenison. I bombed. I was shocked. I got on it. You know, Jim Carrey was auditioning. You know, I'm going, okay, I'm not on this show. Got on it.
萨姆·肯尼森。我搞砸了。我很震惊。我还是上了节目。你知道，吉姆·凯瑞当时也在试镜。你知道，我当时想，好吧，我没戏了。结果还是上了。
Then I was told we only had an eight-show pickup for the first time in the history of Saturday Night Live. It wasn't a full 20. Wow. Hit the ground running, or we're out of here. Right. And then the church lay was just a fluke. Is something I did in my stand-up, or we'll try it.
然后我被告知，我们只有八集的预订，这在《周六夜现场》历史上还是第一次。不是完整的20集。哇。必须立刻进入状态，否则就得走人。没错。然后“教堂女士”只是个意外。那是我单口喜剧里的一个段子，或者说我们打算试试。
So the week I did the church lay, the first week I, and I'd never done sketch comedy. I'd only done stand-up. Wow. Incredible. So Neil Young calls. Sure. I do.
所以做“教堂女士”的那一周，第一周，我以前从没演过小品喜剧。我只做过单口。哇。太不可思议了。然后尼尔·杨打来电话。当然。我做了。
Of course he does. And I got to go down to... At least long messages, doesn't he, Daniel? Oh, man. Look, one of my first impressions. I actually, I was at a Neil Young concert once. I go, Dana Carvey backstage. Dana Carvey, come back stage.
他当然会打。我得去……至少留言很长，对吧，丹尼尔？哦，天哪。看，我最早的模仿之一。其实，我曾经在尼尔·杨的演唱会上。我说，达纳·卡维在后台。达纳·卡维，到后台来。
Concert. And so I went back and Neil was in his bus making pasta. Yeah. This is going to kick in a little while. Could you do a little bit of time? So I had this old bit, hacky bit I used to do of Neil Young doing a commercial for McDonald's. I'm not proud of it.
演唱会。所以我去了后台，尼尔正在他的大巴上做意大利面。是的。这过一会儿就会起作用。你能稍微拖延一下时间吗？所以我有一个旧段子，我以前常做的蹩脚段子，关于尼尔·杨拍麦当劳广告。我对此并不引以为傲。
Well, I dreamed I saw the golden arches in the yellow haze of the sun. I do the whole thing, 10 years later, my kids are in junior high and a dad comes up to me and goes, hey, man, I got this Neil Young bootleg album. You're the first track. No way. Anyway, way. Wow.
嗯，我梦见我在太阳的黄色雾霾中看到了金拱门。我把整段都演了，10年后，我的孩子们上初中时，一个爸爸走过来对我说，嘿，伙计，我有一张尼尔·杨的盗版专辑。你是第一首歌。不会吧。总之，就是这样。哇。
But anyway, so church lady, I put it in the read-through. It did so, so Neil Young had called the next day. So I had to go down to Madison Square Garden. He was doing a garage band motif. He told Lauren, I need some kind of angry woman. So I went down there and did it that night on Wednesday when they picked the show. I came back and found out that church lady just barely got on.
但不管怎样，所以“教堂女士”，我把它放进了剧本朗读会。效果很好，所以尼尔·杨第二天就打了电话。所以我不得不去麦迪逊广场花园。他当时在搞一个车库乐队的主题。他告诉洛恩，我需要一个那种愤怒的女人。所以我那天晚上去了，在他们选定节目的周三演了。我回来后发现“教堂女士”差点没能上节目。
That my buddy, Phil Hartman said, I think we should give it a chance. So it was the last sketch in the first show thinking this isn't going to fly. And I'd never done it with the dress. So the minute I said Victoria Jackson was going off and Jesus, that's this and that. And then I just said, well, isn't that special? Boom. Boom.
我哥们菲尔·哈特曼说，我觉得我们应该给它一个机会。所以它是第一集里的最后一个小品，当时觉得这肯定不行。而且我以前从没穿过那件裙子演过。所以当我一说维多利亚·杰克逊要走了，天哪，这啊那的。然后我只是说，嗯，那不是很特别吗？砰。砰。
Mic drop. Then all the nerves went away. And that last slot on SNL, as you know, and you guys know, because you've hosted. The death spot. That's where they kind of either bury stuff or try stuff that's kind of new. Yeah. Or they don't think it has a chance.
麦克风掉落。然后所有的紧张感都消失了。正如你们所知，你们也主持过，SNL的最后一个位置。死亡点。那是他们要么埋没东西，要么尝试一些新东西的地方。是的。或者他们觉得没戏的地方。
Right. Yeah. But it's kind of freeing, right, Dana? You must have felt kind of like, fuck it. I was so nervous before I went out there because I was, I literally played a pizza parlor in Martinez, California in July. Right. I played to four people.
没错。是的。但这挺让人放松的，对吧，达纳？你当时一定觉得，去他妈的。我上台前太紧张了，因为我，我真的在七月份在加州马丁内斯的披萨店演过。没错。我只给四个人演。
Half the audience hated me. These are the jokes. Then this is October 10th. I go out to Lawrence house. I hang out with Paul McCartney and Chevy Chase. I go to Yankees games with Lauren. I live there for like a month. I go on the show.
一半观众讨厌我。这就是笑话。然后这是10月10日。我去了洛恩家。我和保罗·麦卡特尼、切维·切斯待在一起。我和洛恩一起去看洋基队的比赛。我在那儿住了大概一个月。我上了节目。
I'm shy. I'm terrified. I was swearing at myself in the mirror before the show. You know, you motherfucker. Yeah. Just to get rid of that. So then church lady moves up first. I'm in the, I didn't know I was in the cold opening with, so I'm in that.
我很害羞。我很害怕。演出前我在镜子里对自己骂脏话。你知道，你这个混蛋。是的。只是为了摆脱那种感觉。然后“教堂女士”排到了第一位。我在，我不知道我还在冷开场里，所以我参与了那个。
I'm doing a alien sketch. And then I do Chopin Broccoli at the end. I mean, one of my all time favorites, Chopin Broccoli. Why that stuck so hard. I don't know, Sean. It's so funny. It's so bizarre. I don't know that one.
我在演一个外星人小品。然后我在最后演了“切西兰花”。我是说，我最喜欢的作品之一，“切西兰花”。为什么它这么深入人心。我不知道，肖恩。它太搞笑了。太离奇了。我不知道那个。
How do I not know that one? Chopin Broccoli. I didn't do it that much. It's the songs called Chopin Broccoli. And he sits at the piano and it's just chords. Like a, like a ballad, like a rock ballad. And it's Chopin Broccoli. I used to do George Bush doing Chopin Broccoli too.
我怎么会不知道那个？“切西兰花”。我演得不多。那首歌叫“切西兰花”。他坐在钢琴前，全是和弦。像一首民谣，像一首摇滚民谣。然后就是“切西兰花”。我以前也演过乔治·布什唱“切西兰花”。
Can I hear that? You know, Chopin Broccoli. You know, it's so bad. But the premise of it, Jason, was that he, which Lauren liked a guy who had to play his new songs for the record company executives. It was Gornie Weaver and Phil Hartman. And it was like, well, I don't know if I've got anything. I'll try it.
我能听听吗？你知道，“切西兰花”。你知道，太烂了。但它的前提是，杰森，他，洛恩喜欢一个必须为唱片公司高管演奏新歌的家伙。那是西格妮·韦弗和菲尔·哈特曼。就像是，嗯，我不知道我有没有什么东西。我试试。
And he says, he's cold as ice. It's like a foreigner thing. And then he's riffing paradise. He's making it up. And then finally, and she's a, she's Chopin Broccoli. And that became Chopin Broccoli. She chops. So that was just that.
他说，他冷若冰霜。就像外国人的那种感觉。然后他在即兴创作天堂。他在编造。最后，她是，她是“切西兰花”。这就成了“切西兰花”。她切。所以就是那样。
Like what, like Jay, whatever the idea was, it would always come back to, he's just chopping broccoli. He's just chopping broccoli. Now I do 10 minute renditions when I do stand up. Oh, you do? Riff. Oh yeah. I do it with a guitar.
就像，杰，不管是什么点子，最后总会回到，他只是在切西兰花。他只是在切西兰花。现在我做单口时会演10分钟的版本。哦，真的吗？即兴。哦，是的。我用吉他演。
I do all. I would love to see that. But that was the most nervous I'd ever been was before that. The first, the, the, because I don't, when you audition for stand up live, don't you have to have a couple of impressions? And if so, do you, do you still do the ones that you did originally for your first audition? Yeah. I mean, I probably did Jimmy Stewart.
我全做。我很想看那个。但那是我有史以来最紧张的一次，就在那之前。第一次，因为我，当你为单口喜剧试镜时，难道不需要几个模仿秀吗？如果是这样，你还做你第一次试镜时做的那些吗？是的。我是说，我可能做了吉米·斯图尔特。
I think I did Chopin Broccoli a little bit. Well, what happened was I auditioned in different, I didn't want to audition at the comedy store or the improv cause I always bomb in those two places. So Lorne Michaels comes around with the show. They need four new cast members. So I was playing a little club on the West side called Igby's, which is a hundred Cedar low ceiling hot club. And I played there a lot.
我想我稍微做了一点“切西兰花”。嗯，发生的事情是我在不同的地方试镜，我不想在喜剧商店或即兴表演俱乐部试镜，因为我在那两个地方总是搞砸。所以洛恩·迈克尔斯带着节目来了。他们需要四个新演员。所以我当时在西区一个叫Igby's的小俱乐部表演，那是一个一百个座位、低天花板、很热的俱乐部。我经常在那里演。
Rosie O'Donnell was headlining the week that Lorne Michaels was in town. I didn't know her, but I knew the owner and I said, ask Rosie if she'll give me a spot on her set. And I'm going to bring Lorne Michaels. And Rosie said, yes. So then I, there that night, Lorne Michaels is going to see me do stand up. Wow. And I met Rosie and she seemed, she seemed like an old soul.
洛恩·迈克尔斯在城里的那一周，罗西·欧唐内是头牌。我不认识她，但我认识老板，我说，问问罗西能不能给我一个名额。我要带洛恩·迈克尔斯来。罗西答应了。所以那天晚上，洛恩·迈克尔斯要看我表演单口。哇。我见到了罗西，她看起来，她看起来像个老灵魂。
She never seemed, she just was like kind of to have that Rosie confidence, you know? Yeah. So I said, maybe I should go on first. So, you know, I call him first. So I'm standing in the wings. Lorne Michaels come to see me. I've been at this 10 years. I failed at everything I'd done had been canceled or bombed.
她从来没表现出，她只是有一种罗西式的自信，你知道吗？是的。所以我说，也许我应该先上。所以，你知道，我先叫他。所以我站在侧台。洛恩·迈克尔斯来看我。我干这行10年了。我做的一切都失败了，都被取消了或者搞砸了。
And then Lorne Michaels walks in. Holy shit. After him, Brandon Tardik off the head of NBC at the time. Then I'm like, oh God, he brought the head of the network. Then share. They came in. And so, but I was nervous, but I had 40 minutes instead of five. And I think that's what helped 40.
然后洛恩·迈克尔斯走了进来。该死。在他之后，当时的NBC总裁布兰登·塔迪科夫。然后我想，天哪，他把电视网的总裁带来了。然后雪儿。他们进来了。所以，我很紧张，但我有40分钟而不是5分钟。我想这就是有帮助的地方，40分钟。
Yeah, because Rosie cleared the decks. You know, I just did the night with her and then she got a sitcom out of it. Oh, wow. Really? Yeah. That's incredible. So just to jump back and forth a little bit, Dana. So you, you leave SNL, you go and you do a sitcom as we mentioned.
是的，因为罗西清空了场地。你知道，我只是和她一起演了那晚，然后她就因此得到了一部情景喜剧。哦，哇。真的吗？是的。太不可思议了。所以稍微跳跃一下，达纳。所以你，你离开了SNL，你去演了一部情景喜剧，正如我们提到的。
Oh, no, sorry. Not sitcom. Comedy show. I did the Dana Carvey show in 1996 with Steve Carell, Stephen Colbert, Louis C.K., Dino Steppinopoulos, Robert Carlock, John Glazer, John Glazer, my good friend, John Glazer. Oh, we had Louis C.K. was my head writer. I gave the first John.
哦，不，抱歉。不是情景喜剧。喜剧节目。我在1996年做了《达纳·卡维秀》，和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、斯蒂芬·科尔伯特、路易·CK、迪诺·斯蒂芬诺普洛斯、罗伯特·卡洛克、约翰·格雷泽，约翰·格雷泽，我的好朋友，约翰·格雷泽。哦，我们有路易·CK是我的首席编剧。我给了第一个约翰。
Louis C.K. was your head writer. Steve Carell was a writer, as we mentioned. Performer. Yeah. Performer. And Carell, I mean. I call him the two steves. Smigal, of course Smigal.
路易·CK是你的首席编剧。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是编剧，正如我们提到的。表演者。是的。表演者。还有卡瑞尔，我是说。我叫他们两个史蒂夫。斯米格尔，当然还有斯米格尔。
Smigal, yeah, was my co-creator. Was your co-creator, right? Yeah. So, I mean, this is an unbelievable all-star team. Yeah. And just, of course, because Showbiz is bats a thousand, they cancel it. Well, there's a story behind that. First of all.
斯米格尔，是的，是我的联合创作者。是你的联合创作者，对吧？是的。所以，我是说，这是一个令人难以置信的全明星团队。是的。当然，因为演艺圈总是这样，他们取消了它。嗯，这背后有个故事。首先。
Well, let's hear it. I had two weeks to think about it because I miss sketch comedy. And Smigal and I had a great connection on there. You know, we did Carson and a lot of different McLaughlin group things together. So. Oh, God, I love that. Issue one. Jason, Jason, Jason, Jason and the all-get-oughts.
嗯，让我们听听。我有两周时间考虑，因为我想念小品喜剧。我和斯米格尔在那上面有很好的联系。你知道，我们一起做了卡森和很多不同的麦克劳林小组的东西。所以。哦，天哪，我喜欢那个。第一期。杰森，杰森，杰森，杰森和那些人。
Sean Connery. No, that was just rhythmically riding up things. Smigal, we just connected rhythmically. So, I decided I wanted to do it on HBO. I go, you could do 10. You could still have a life, you know. So then, I think Bob Iger was in the room. I don't want to blame him.
肖恩·康纳利。不，那只是节奏感地写东西。斯米格尔，我们只是在节奏上产生了共鸣。所以，我决定我想在HBO做。我说，你可以做10集。你仍然可以有生活，你知道。所以然后，我想鲍勃·伊格尔当时在房间里。我不想责怪他。
I like Bob, but they go, come on, do it at ABC. You want to do it at ABC. We could do it at ABC. It would be great. You know, the great Brad Gray. So then, and then Louie and Robert at that point kind of wanted the budget and the money of ABC. And the idea was, oh, you have a Disney face.
我喜欢鲍勃，但他们说，来吧，在ABC做。你想在ABC做。我们可以在ABC做。那会很棒。你知道，伟大的布拉德·格雷。所以然后，路易和罗伯特当时有点想要ABC的预算和钱。当时的想法是，哦，你有一张迪士尼的脸。
You're kind of like Carol Burnett. You can work in prime time. Okay, terrific. Let's do it. And then they gave me an extra million. You know, okay. People like numbers. That'll do it.
你有点像卡罗尔·伯内特。你可以在黄金时段工作。好吧，太棒了。我们做吧。然后他们给了我额外的一百万。你知道，好吧。人们喜欢数字。那就可以了。
I never cared about the money that much, but like you guys. But my point is, you know, but the first show, we were banking shows in New York. We moved to New York because my wife and I didn't want to raise our kids in the valley, which probably would have been fine. So then we bank a sketch that Louie wrote, which was Bill Clinton. I didn't have a good Bill Clinton, but it's like, he's giving his speech to the nation and we can do better and all that. And then he opens his shirt and he's got teats like a dog and he's going to breastfeed puppies.
我从来不在乎钱，但像你们一样。但我的意思是，你知道，第一集，我们在纽约储备节目。我们搬到纽约是因为我和我妻子不想在山谷里抚养孩子，那可能也没问题。所以我们储备了一个路易写的小品，是关于比尔·克林顿的。我没有一个好的比尔·克林顿模仿，但就像，他正在向全国发表讲话，我们可以做得更好之类的。然后他解开衬衫，他有像狗一样的乳头，他要去给小狗喂奶。
So actual live puppies and I will feed the nation. So I got the chart of the, we were at 16 million when Bill appeared and it goes like a ball. We were like at two million hanging in. Viewers, you mean? Once you exposed the row of teats. Yeah, the deets. And then we were just the critics lambasted us. And so we made it through eight shows.
所以是真正的活小狗，我会喂养全国。所以我拿到了图表，比尔出现时我们有1600万观众，然后像球一样掉下来。我们大概只有200万观众在看。你是说观众？一旦你露出了那一排乳头。是的，那些乳头。然后我们被评论家痛骂。所以我们坚持了八集。
And then it became a cult classic. So had you been on something that wasn't a mass audience broadcast platform, perhaps it would have been a little bit more embraced. Did you find that you were more of a populist audience than? Yeah, there was no Netflix. There was no anything. There was just maybe, I guess, Comedy Central or HBO. Yeah.
然后它成了一部邪典经典。所以如果你是在一个不是大众广播平台的平台上，也许它会更受欢迎。你发现你比大众观众更受欢迎吗？是的，那时没有Netflix。什么都没有。可能只有，我想，喜剧中心或HBO。是的。
I remember that coming out. I remember the Dana Carvey show. And I was like in my head, I was like, oh, finally somebody gave the guy a shot. It just seemed like natural that you would have that shot. It hasn't worked. You know, Martin Short tried. I mean, people have tried in prime time. It's tough.
我记得那个节目出来的时候。我记得《达纳·卡维秀》。我当时想，哦，终于有人给这家伙一个机会了。你得到那个机会似乎很自然。它没成功。你知道，马丁·肖特试过。我是说，人们在黄金时段试过。很难。
It's tough, isn't it? Yeah. It's got to be the right platform. Didn't Marty do it? Didn't Marty do it with? Well, he did one recently. With Maya. With Maya.
很难，不是吗？是的。必须是正确的平台。马蒂不是做过吗？马蒂不是和……一起做过吗？嗯，他最近做了一个。和玛雅一起。和玛雅。
Yeah, he did with Maya. Yeah. So, but there was some brilliant stuff in that, some great stuff. The A team of writers we had. And so Josh Greenbaum did a documentary that came out a couple of years ago. Yeah. I heard about that. Yeah.
是的，他和玛雅一起做的。是的。所以，但里面有一些精彩的东西，一些很棒的东西。我们拥有的编剧梦之队。所以乔希·格林鲍姆拍了一部纪录片，几年前出来的。是的。我听说过那个。是的。
Too funny to fail. Yeah. I'm just going to go on a limb and say it. There's just, we've reached peak content. I always do. People talk about content creators. This is a kind of, I don't know if I brought it up. It kind of makes me mad because I feel like content is what I put between the walls of
《太好笑而失败》。是的。我只想冒险说一句。我们已经达到了内容的巅峰。我总是这么做。人们谈论内容创作者。这是一种，我不知道我是否提过。这让我有点生气，因为我觉得内容是我放在墙壁之间用来隔绝冷热的东西。
my house to insulate, you know, from the cold or the heat. That's, that's content. Right. If you call what you do content, just, you're just making filler. Like, okay. Thanks. Hey man. I don't make content.
我的房子，你知道，用来隔热。那是，那是内容。对吧。如果你把你做的事情称为内容，你只是在制造填充物。好吧。谢谢。嘿，伙计。我不制造内容。
Something to stuff the pipe with. Right. But I'm also not making art. It should be noted. No, yeah. The audience is the entertainer now. It was like you'd have Frank Sinatra on stage or whatever in the audience to be out there. Now the audience is entertainers as well with social media and Instagram.
用来塞管子的东西。没错。但我也不是在创作艺术。应该指出这一点。不，是的。观众现在是艺人。就像你以前有弗兰克·辛纳屈在舞台上，或者观众在台下。现在观众也是艺人，通过社交媒体和Instagram。
Yeah. We're all posting. We're all entertaining now. Or I'll say we'd all be famous for 15 minutes. Right. Yeah. Now it's like, we'll all be stars. Well, speaking of which, I mean, your longevity and relevance has been so sustained for so
是的。我们都在发帖。我们现在都是艺人。或者我会说我们都会出名15分钟。没错。是的。现在就像，我们都会成为明星。嗯，说到这个，我是说，你的长寿和相关性一直持续了这么
long. You, I mean, you can't, you can't attribute all that to luck and talent. Right. I mean, is there, is there a third magic component that you're working with? Cause, you know, I, I'm with, I'm with Sean. I prefer a weekly dose of you, but you are, you are around and fantastic still. And I mean, what's your secret? I don't know.
久。你，我是说，你不能，你不能把这一切归功于运气和天赋。对吧。我是说，有没有，有没有第三种魔法成分在起作用？因为，你知道，我，我和肖恩在一起。我更喜欢每周看你一次，但你仍然在，而且依然很棒。我是说，你的秘诀是什么？我不知道。
I'm a little bit like you, Jason, I think from what I've heard is I, I really kind of am a homebody a little bit. You know, I've got my keyboards and my guitar, my lovely wife and all the cool shows I could watch. Right. So, you know, I never, I just do the, I mean, what, what do you guys say to yourself? It's cognitive behavioral therapy. Right.
我有点像你，杰森，我想从我听到的来看，我，我确实有点像个宅男。你知道，我有我的键盘和吉他，我可爱的妻子，还有所有我能看的酷节目。所以，你知道，我从来不，我只是做，我是说，你们对自己说什么？这是认知行为疗法。对吧。
No one's thinking of you. Never feel sorry for yourself. When I had those few things bomb and the bomb, the botch bypass, that's a whole other story in the 90s. In your heart. Yeah. That thing. I was a freshman and I was really, really small.
没人会想到你。永远不要为自己感到难过。当我那几件事搞砸了，还有那个搞砸的搭桥手术，那是90年代的另一个故事。在你的心脏。是的。那件事。我当时是个新生，我真的很，真的很小。
Like you had, you had like an operation on the wrong. I remember you talking about this on the wrong artery or something. Right. Well, yeah. As, as quick as I can. Yeah. I had familial hypoclestremia. I didn't know it.
就像你，你做了一个错误的手术。我记得你谈过这个，在错误的动脉上还是什么的。对吧。嗯，是的。尽可能快地。是的。我有家族性高胆固醇血症。我不知道。
My cholesterol was 400. My LDL was 300. Oh my God. And I didn't know it. So at 42, I started having symptoms. They found out I had a blocked LAD, but I never had a heart attack. Big distinction. Cause I was so fit at the time.
我的胆固醇是400。我的低密度脂蛋白是300。哦，天哪。我不知道。所以在42岁时，我开始出现症状。他们发现我有一个LAD阻塞，但我从来没有心脏病发作。很大的区别。因为我当时身体很好。
And so then I had someone throw in some stents and I didn't know that sometimes your body doesn't know how to react to a little metal sheath in the artery. Surprise. So it'll, it'll scar tissue up, therefore blocking you again. So I had like six of those. They had to keep rotor, rudering and putting new stents in. It was all in this one area of the LAD. Usually people get squeamish and leave the room at this point.
所以然后我让人放了一些支架，我不知道有时你的身体不知道如何对动脉里的金属鞘做出反应。惊喜。所以它会产生疤痕组织，从而再次阻塞你。所以我大概有六个那样的。他们不得不一直疏通并放入新的支架。这一切都在LAD的这个区域。通常人们在这个时候会感到恶心并离开房间。
No. I'm used to the first diagonal. This is a crossover episode of hypochondriac. I'm a heart attack doctor, right? Well, I love, I love menopause stuff. We'll do a public service after this where I say this thing, this thing is arrested now. In essence, if you follow the protocol, heart disease, you should never be surprised when you're having a heart attack.
不。我习惯了第一个对角线。这是一个疑病症患者的交叉剧集。我是心脏病医生，对吧？嗯，我喜欢，我喜欢更年期的事情。我们之后会做一个公共服务，我会说这件事，这件事现在被逮捕了。本质上，如果你遵循协议，心脏病，当你心脏病发作时，你不应该感到惊讶。
There's so many things they do. But anyway, so then they said, well, we'll do a simple bypass. You keep restinocene. These were these old fashioned stents. So they swung over my mammary arteries, which never block up. Right. So the surgeon I picked in Northern California was considered the greatest in the world. I had a private jet in the air to take me to Cedar Sinai, but I was convinced by well
他们做的事情太多了。但不管怎样，他们说，嗯，我们做一个简单的搭桥手术。你一直再狭窄。这些是老式的支架。所以他们绕过了我的乳内动脉，那从来不会阻塞。对吧。所以我选的北加州的医生被认为是世界上最伟大的。我有一架私人飞机在空中带我去雪松西奈医院，但我被好心人说服了
meaning people to go with this surgeon. He ended up, instead of attaching a hose to a big trunk of a tree, he attached it to a healthy diagonal off the other side. So the blockage was still there. So when they found it, I was like, holy shit. At that point, I'd had so many angioplasties, I was kind of awake. So they wrote or rooted it, and he goes, you want me to push it a little harder? And I go, yeah, let's go for it.
去选这个医生。他最终，没有把软管连接到树的主干上，而是把它连接到了另一侧的一个健康的对角线上。所以阻塞仍然存在。所以当他们发现它时，我当时想，该死。在那一点上，我已经做了太多的血管成形术，我有点清醒。所以他们疏通了它，他说，你想让我再用力推一下吗？我说，是的，让我们试试吧。
So now it's never blocked up again. And no one knows why except my Hindu cardiologist, PK Shaw, director of cardiology at Cedar Sinai, said a prayer for me at Mother Teresa's tomb. And my 91 year old mother-in-law, she was probably 60 then, said a prayer for me at a wishing well outside of Dublin. Just put it out there. Sure. And so that happened.
所以现在它再也没有阻塞过。没人知道为什么，除了我的印度心脏病专家PK肖，雪松西奈医院的心脏病学主任，在特蕾莎修女的墓前为我祈祷。我91岁的岳母，她当时大概60岁，在都柏林外的一个许愿池为我祈祷。只是把它放出来。当然。所以那发生了。
And then I won on the protocol. My cholesterol now, my LDL, which is the real dangerous one, is 45 and it was 300. Amazing. So here I am. No changes to your diet at all? Oh, complete shift on the diet. I know you guys teach Sean about his diet. I was like that in my 30s.
然后我赢得了协议。我的胆固醇现在，我的低密度脂蛋白，也就是真正危险的那种，是45，而以前是300。太神奇了。所以我在这里。你的饮食完全没有改变吗？哦，饮食上有彻底的转变。我知道你们教肖恩关于他的饮食。我在30多岁时就是那样。
You know, I'd have a big giant turkey sandwich with mayonnaise or macaroni and cheese. I was eating kind of like a kid from the 60s or 70s. So anyway, I did change the diet and I just paid more attention to everything and stress. Are you vegan now or anything like that? No. Metatranian diet has the best results. Look at you. So I do a lot of Sam.
你知道，我会吃一个巨大的火鸡三明治配蛋黄酱或通心粉奶酪。我吃得像个60或70年代的孩子。所以不管怎样，我确实改变了饮食，我只是更加注意一切和压力。你现在是纯素食者还是什么的吗？不。地中海饮食有最好的结果。看看你。所以我吃很多萨姆。
What part of the Mediterranean diet? Metatranian diet. I love the Mediterranean. I like the Mediterranean diet. I like the Greek islands. I like the salmon. You know, all of it. No.
地中海饮食的哪一部分？地中海饮食。我喜欢地中海。我喜欢地中海饮食。我喜欢希腊群岛。我喜欢三文鱼。你知道，所有这些。不。
Croatia is the place to go. Sorry. Do you have to watch your heart rate? Like can you exercise vigorously and all that stuff? Yeah, because I never had any heart damage or heart attack, which is usually people kind of glaze over at this point as well. Like I don't, I really, really have a high V2O max for my age. I mean, I hike up mountains.
克罗地亚是去的地方。抱歉。你必须注意你的心率吗？比如你能剧烈运动之类的吗？是的，因为我从来没有任何心脏损伤或心脏病发作，通常人们在这个时候也会有点走神。就像我不，我真的，真的有很高的V2O最大值，对于我的年龄来说。我是说，我徒步爬山。
Yeah. Yeah. I don't have any, any, any governor on that. I feel like bionic now. That's great. I'd love to go for a hike for you guys because you go, damn, you weren't lying. You know what I want? You know what I say yesterday?
是的。是的。我对此没有任何，没有任何，没有任何限制。我现在感觉像仿生人。那太棒了。我很想为你们去徒步旅行，因为你们会说，该死，你没撒谎。你知道我想要什么吗？你知道我昨天说什么吗？
Kevin Nielen's got a hiking show. Yeah. It's a little, a little, a little chat for a while. I was on that. For a while. Yeah. Pay attention. Yeah.
凯文·尼伦有一个徒步节目。是的。聊了一会儿。我上过那个。有一段时间。是的。注意。是的。
I was on that show with him. Yeah. And I just kept accelerating just a little bit on the hill, just more and more. And I was like, so let me, let me understand this. Yeah. Kevin was another one of my partners in crime on SNL. Hans and Franz. Hans and Franz.
我和他一起上了那个节目。是的。我只是在山上稍微加速了一点，越来越多。然后我就想，所以让我，让我理解这个。是的。凯文是我在SNL的另一个犯罪伙伴。汉斯和弗朗茨。汉斯和弗朗茨。
You guys were, I love that maybe more than anything else. As far as what makes me laugh. Two, two wounded idiots who are paranoid and delusional and keep challenging an invisible audience. Yeah. Yeah. And if you think we're not properly pumped, I could take your flab and stretch it into the shape of a rope ladder so you could crawl down back in the sewer.
你们，我喜欢那个可能超过任何其他东西。就让我发笑而言。两个，两个受伤的白痴，偏执且妄想，不断挑战一个隐形的观众。是的。是的。如果你认为我们没有充分泵起来，我可以把你的赘肉拉伸成绳梯的形状，这样你就可以爬回下水道。
Cause that's where Lewis lives. Lewis lives. It's just that, that, because I became very fey with that character. Right. And that's glorious. Right. Which made it more fun for me. It's really funny.
因为那是路易住的地方。路易住的地方。只是那个，那个，因为我那个角色变得非常娘娘腔。对吧。那太光荣了。对吧。这让我觉得更有趣。真的很有趣。
It's so great. And now a word from our sponsor. This episode is brought to you in part by visible. You usually pay more for one line of wireless than if you're on a shared plan, right? Why is that? Cause your phone is your phone. Wouldn't it be great if you could get the same deal on your own line? Meet visible.
太棒了。现在是赞助商时间。本集部分由Visible赞助。你通常为一条无线线路支付的费用比你在共享计划中支付的要多，对吧？为什么会这样？因为你的手机就是你的手机。如果你能在自己的线路上获得同样的优惠，那不是很好吗？认识一下Visible。
Visible offers their best rate all on one line, not four lines, not three, not even two. Just a one line wireless plan with unlimited data for $30 a month. Taxes and fees included all powered by Verizon. Visible is flexible and can save you money without a family plan. Switch today at visible.com and get $20 off your first month when you use code smartless20. That's smartless20, a special offer for smartless listener. Offer ends March 31st. New activation and offer code required.
Visible在一条线路上提供他们最好的费率，不是四条线路，不是三条，甚至不是两条。只是一个每月30美元的无限数据单线无线计划。包含税费，全部由Verizon提供支持。Visible很灵活，可以在没有家庭计划的情况下为你省钱。今天在visible.com切换，使用代码smartless20，你的第一个月可减免20美元。那是smartless20，给smartless听众的特别优惠。优惠于3月31日结束。需要新的激活和优惠代码。
For data management practices, learn more at visible.com. Additional terms apply. Smartless is brought to you in part by Macy's Valentine's Day is around the corner. And guess what? Outside of doing the kind of chocolates or the flowers or whatever, which are, I just got to say pretty lame. It's tough to know what to get that special someone for Valentine's Day. You don't know what to do. You're like, I don't want it to be too much.
有关数据管理实践，请在visible.com了解更多。适用附加条款。Smartless部分由梅西百货赞助。情人节就在拐角处。你猜怎么着？除了做那种巧克力或鲜花之类的，我不得不说相当蹩脚。很难知道情人节给那个特别的人买什么。你不知道该做什么。你就像，我不想太多。
Or I don't want it to be too little. I don't want it to be this. I don't want it. And you get kind of, I know I do. I get paralyzed because I don't know what to do. So if you're stumped on what to get your special someone, Macy's has you covered with their gift finder. They've got amazing gifts at any price from lux to $25 and under. Check out these great ideas at Macy's.com slash gift finder.
或者我不想太少。我不想是这个。我不想。你有点，我知道我这样。我变得瘫痪，因为我不知道该做什么。所以如果你对给特别的人买什么感到困惑，梅西百货的礼物查找器可以帮你。他们有任何价格的惊人礼物，从奢侈品到25美元及以下。在Macys.com/giftfinder查看这些好主意。
So Macy's has the best PJs for cozy nights in. They do have the flowers. If you want to just get that for the day night or the candy and the chocolates, you know, and they have a lot of the most sought after gifts at Macy's. They got like, you know, the incredible brands, Kate Spade and Coach and Ralph Lauren and Swarovski and more. And you can treat yourself. Treat yourself. You deserve a beautiful fragrance. You know, there's some self care beauty stuff or just some beautiful jewelry.
所以梅西百货有最适合舒适夜晚的睡衣。他们确实有鲜花。如果你想为约会之夜买那个，或者糖果和巧克力，你知道，他们在梅西百货有很多最受欢迎的礼物。他们有，你知道，令人难以置信的品牌，凯特·丝蓓和蔻驰和拉尔夫·劳伦和施华洛世奇等等。你可以犒劳自己。犒劳自己。你值得拥有美丽的香水。你知道，有一些自我护理美容产品或只是一些美丽的珠宝。
You know, why not? This is what Macy's is going to do. I'm going to do the gift finder for myself elf elf. Again, that's Macy's.com slash gift finder to find the best gifts this Valentine's Day. All right. Back to the show. Now, you know, I want to talk about ask about you being a dad because I'm like, I have a bunch of your friends are your friends because they make you laugh. Right. Jason will make me laugh so hard.
你知道，为什么不呢？这就是梅西百货要做的。我要为自己用礼物查找器。再次，那是Macys.com/giftfinder，在这个情人节找到最好的礼物。好的。回到节目。现在，你知道，我想谈谈问问你作为父亲，因为我，我有很多你的朋友是你的朋友，因为他们让你笑。对吧。杰森会让我笑得那么厉害。
Another friend of mine, Kerry, makes me laugh. Oh, you guys have a great thing going on. Oh, thanks. But, you know, and I'm always kind of amazed like being around Jason in front of his kids or Will in front of his kids. Sometimes their kids will laugh at something to say. And most of the time they'll kind of like roll their eyes. Oh, yeah. And from the outside, I'm like, no, wait, your dad is fucking hysterical. Like I can't imagine being one of your kids.
我的另一个朋友，凯瑞，让我笑。哦，你们有很好的事情发生。哦，谢谢。但是，你知道，我总是有点惊讶，像在杰森的孩子面前或威尔的孩子面前。有时他们的孩子会因为说的话而笑。大多数时候他们会有点翻白眼。哦，是的。从外面看，我像，不，等等，你爸爸太搞笑了。我无法想象成为你的孩子之一。
Like I'm always blown away when kids don't find their famous funny parents. They're just so tired of the material. I'm just, you know, aren't you guys, you're most of the time just regular, right? Most of the time. Yeah. And then if you get around someone to make you laugh like me, David Spade, hysterical, then that ping pong effect starts to happen. Right. But, you know, I'm mostly just just regular and they try to make me laugh, you know.
就像我总是被孩子们不觉得他们著名的搞笑父母好笑而震惊。他们只是太厌倦了那些素材。我只是，你知道，你们不是大多数时候只是普通的吗？大多数时候。是的。然后如果你遇到让你笑的人，像我，大卫·斯佩德，歇斯底里，那么那种乒乓效应就开始发生了。对吧。但是，你知道，我大多数时候只是，只是普通的，他们试图让我笑，你知道。
Oh, really? Yeah. I love watching my kids sense of humor develop. Oh, yeah. Like it's really interesting to see, to see a human being discover sarcasm and irony, you know, like it's just, you know, obviously it's after they learn the language and then, then they learn like how to like twist and bend stuff and not break it. I mean, it's just like, Maple's got it down.
哦，真的吗？是的。我喜欢看着我孩子们的幽默感发展。哦，是的。就像看到，看到一个人发现讽刺和反讽真的很有趣，你知道，就像它只是，你知道，显然是在他们学会语言之后，然后，然后他们学会了如何像扭曲和弯曲东西而不打破它。我是说，这就像，梅普尔已经掌握了。
His daughter, Maple. Yeah. I'm in love with both of his daughters. But Maple said to me the other day when we were out together, all of us, we were saying goodbye and she, she didn't even get up off the couch. Say goodbye. She turns to me and she goes, I love you, sweetheart. You have a great evening. I mean, and she's like, you know,
他的女儿，梅普尔。是的。我爱上了他的两个女儿。但梅普尔前几天在我们都在一起时对我说，我们正在告别，她，她甚至没有从沙发上起来。说再见。她转向我，她说，我爱你，甜心。祝你有个愉快的夜晚。我是说，而且她像，你知道，
Eleven. And it was so sarcastic because we were all saying I love you. Goodbye. They make, they make such leaps all of a sudden. And I hope you guys wrote them down. I wish I had, but one night I was putting my son to bed and he's like four. And I said, Tom, do you know that I love you? And he goes, it's pretty obvious.
十一岁。而且太讽刺了，因为我们都在说我爱你。再见。他们突然取得了这样的飞跃。我希望你们把它们写下来。我希望我有，但有一天晚上我正在哄我儿子睡觉，他大概四岁。我说，汤姆，你知道我爱你吗？他说，这很明显。
He's four. How did, how did you start doing the podcast with Spade? I love the combo of you and Spade. Yeah. Cause you're both fucking naturally. Well, Spade is a hilarious dude. Seeing him up close and it's so lo-fi, but he'll, he'll create a little mini movie in like 30 seconds. So it's like, Hey, I saw that as a boozy.
他四岁。你是怎么开始和斯佩德做播客的？我喜欢你和斯佩德的组合。是的。因为你们两个都他妈的自然。嗯，斯佩德是个搞笑的家伙。近距离看他，而且太低保真了，但他会在30秒内创造一个小迷你电影。所以就像，嘿，我看到了那个。
And he's like, I'm like, you know, hey, you know, and I don't know what I was doing. I got, yeah, wasn't he, it's just so fun to watch and riff around with him. And I met him before SNL, just at this house in Beechwood Canyon. So I met him. He was like 21. What's up, dude? Hey buddy. And everyone always immediately likes David.
他说，我像，你知道，嘿，你知道，我不知道我在做什么。我得到，是的，不是吗，看着他并和他即兴发挥太有趣了。我在SNL之前就见过他，就在比奇伍德峡谷的这所房子里。所以我见到了他。他大概21岁。怎么了，伙计？嘿，哥们。每个人总是立刻喜欢大卫。
And I did. And then I interacted with, he came to SNL. We were there as band mates for three, four years. And then, you know, I was up North race and my kids, but every time we see each other, it's like you guys being one second. So when I moved back down here and I live at a place that's a walkable to Koi, I started having dinner with David a lot. And that's where we would go.
我也喜欢。然后我互动，他来到SNL。我们作为乐队伙伴在那里待了三、四年。然后，你知道，我在北方抚养我的孩子，但每次我们见面，就像你们在一起一秒钟。所以当我搬回这里，我住在一个离Koi很近的地方，我开始经常和David吃晚餐。那就是我们会去的地方。
And one time we went to some other restaurant. Let's just go over there. Cause I like to have a conversation. I don't like to, it's like when I met you, Jason, it's like, oh, Jason Bateman, this is cool. And then we were at the Laker game and we're up in the Tester andus box. And it's literally, okay, what? Well, how are you? Yeah, I'm fine.
有一次我们去了另一家餐厅。我们去那边吧。因为我喜欢交谈。我不喜欢，就像我见到你时，杰森，就像，哦，杰森·贝特曼，这很酷。然后我们在湖人队的比赛中，我们在Tester andus包厢里。而且真的是，好的，什么？嗯，你好吗？是的，我很好。
What are you doing? You know, so Koi is like, you can talk. But David and I did that. I did a little off the radar podcast. This is a try it out called fantastic. It's online where I had a female sidekick and I had relatives on it, like my sister and stuff. And then I would riff and do long form. Like Obama was a running part of the podcast.
你在做什么？你知道，所以Koi就像，你可以说话。但大卫和我做了那个。我做了一个小小的雷达外播客。这是一个尝试，叫Fantastic。它在网上，我有一个女性搭档，我上面有亲戚，像我姐姐之类的。然后我会即兴发挥并做长篇。像奥巴马是播客的一个运行部分。
Dana, can I come on today? No, my sister's coming on. Michelle, I'm not coming on. So the sister's coming on. No, leave the egg salad out. So I could just riff stuff like that long form. And then I had David on as a guest, our manager heard it, our mutual manager, Mark Gervis and said, you guys got to do a podcast. You got to do a podcast.
达纳，我今天能来吗？不，我姐姐要来了。米歇尔，我不来了。所以姐姐要来了。不，把鸡蛋沙拉拿出来。所以我可以即兴发挥那种长篇。然后我让大卫作为嘉宾，我们的经理听到了，我们的共同经理，马克·格维斯说，你们得做个播客。你们得做个播客。
You know, that kind of thing. Yeah. So then we decided to try it. I will try it. And I'm still not used to this idea. It was kind of fun and I consciously, because I listened to your podcast and I was listening to, I thought it'd be fun to try to do voices and entertain you guys a little bit today. You have. But I, this idea of me is like either I kill or I'm fired, you know, or I'm dismissed for most of my career.
你知道，那种事。是的。所以然后我们决定试试。我会试试。而且我仍然不习惯这个想法。这很有趣，我有意识地，因为我听了你们的播客，我在听，我想今天尝试做声音并娱乐你们一下会很有趣。你做到了。但我，这个关于我的想法是，要么我杀了我要么我被解雇了，你知道，或者我在我职业生涯的大部分时间里被解雇了。
Like I've got to destroy it stand up and I've got to kill. It's a lot of pressure and now being authentic and real funny if it comes up and just be yourself. Yeah. I take the headphone. I go, is that was good? Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
就像我必须在单口喜剧中摧毁它，我必须杀了我。压力很大，现在变得真实且真正有趣，如果它出现了，只是做你自己。是的。我拿耳机。我说，那是好的吗？是的。好的。是的。
It's brand new art form. I mean, everyone would have had these, all those sketch actors that, you know, Shecky Green would have had a podcast or since Caesar or so it's an incredible new art form. Well, but you've just got such a way about you where, I mean, you're so easy to be with and enjoy being around, whether it's in person or watching on TV. Or just hearing your voice. I mean, don't discount that. I know it doesn't feel like you're doing anything. You're so naturally appealing. Yeah.
这是全新的艺术形式。我是说，每个人都会有这些，所有那些小品演员，你知道，谢基·格林会有播客，或者西塞罗，所以这是一个令人难以置信的新艺术形式。嗯，但你就是有这样一种方式，我是说，你太容易相处了，喜欢待在你身边，无论是在现实生活中还是在电视上看着。或者只是听到你的声音。我是说，不要低估这一点。我知道这感觉不像你在做什么。你太自然地吸引人了。是的。
This goes back to like what Jason was saying, what's the missing ingredient? I really think you're so naturally funny. You have no choice in the matter. There are certain people have no choice. You and Farrell and Spade and whomever the list is long, but you have no choice in it. And that's the reason that you have the longevity. I think Jason to answer your question is just you're in it. It's a good dude, but naturally funny, naturally talented.
这回到了杰森所说的，缺失的成分是什么？我真的认为你太自然地有趣了。你别无选择。有些人别无选择。你和法瑞尔和斯佩德和无论名单有多长，但你别无选择。这就是你长寿的原因。我想杰森回答你的问题只是你在里面。是个好家伙，但自然有趣，自然有天赋。
And I think the podcast reveals that to a wider audience of like, you know, you can, you don't, you can just kind of do it and you can do it in conversation. And it's not easy to do. It's a lot harder than people think. And there are a lot of people who are funny or present funny or present really good, but that's somebody else doing a lot of work for them. And then they present to actually be that yourself. It's been very interesting. I'm sure it is for you three, this, this, this art of conversation, what Johnny Carson could do or anybody we admired interviewing in this sort of low five form where it's a conversation as opposed to a straight interview. Yeah, we're bad at interviews.
而且我认为播客向更广泛的受众揭示了这一点，就像，你知道，你可以，你不需要，你可以只是做它，你可以在对话中做它。而且这并不容易做。这比人们想象的要难得多。而且有很多人很有趣或表现得有趣或表现得非常好，但那是别人为他们做了很多工作。然后他们表现得实际上是那样你自己。这非常有趣。我相信对你们三个来说，这种对话的艺术，约翰尼·卡森能做什么或我们钦佩的任何人在这种低保真形式中采访，其中它是一场对话而不是直接采访。是的，我们不擅长采访。
Wanting it to have energy needing to overlap like you would at dinner. Spade and ITZ. I said I was practicing overlapping you during Christmas break. My wife would talk and I would interrupt her just to stay in shape. But I listened to the podcast. Would you have your wife ask really long questions just so you could get ready for Jason? Yeah, yeah. Because sometimes you don't know if you're giving your partner an assist that they literally have started an opus.
想要它有能量需要重叠，就像你在晚餐时那样。斯佩德和ITZ。我说我在寒假期间练习重叠你。我妻子会说话，我会打断她只是为了保持状态。但我听了播客。你会让你妻子问很长的问题只是为了让你为杰森做好准备吗？是的，是的。因为有时你不知道你是否给了你的伴侣一个助攻，他们实际上已经开始了一个巨著。
And then you can tell the steam is out of it. I'm not sure they know are going to land this. So you can interrupt them or not. I'd like to give you half the answer. I'd like to hear from you and then turn you loose. All right. Wait, Dana, do you have, are you, are you other than this, the great podcast with you? You got another podcast.
然后你可以看出蒸汽已经没了。我不确定他们知道要着陆这个。所以你可以打断他们或者不打断。我想给你一半的答案。我想听听你的，然后让你自由。好的。等等，达纳，你有，你是，你是除了这个，伟大的播客和你？你有另一个播客。
Another, yeah. Like an album basically. It's called The Weird Place. I did it with my sons. Really? Oh, that's great. They're very sensitive about the whole Nepo movement. So they're thinking of changing their last name, Nepotism.
另一个，是的。就像一张专辑基本上。它叫《奇怪的地方》。我和我儿子们做的。真的吗？哦，那太棒了。他们对整个Nepo运动非常敏感。所以他们正在考虑改姓，Nepotism。
Yeah, it's so, I mean, it's a new concept. I mean, what the fuck are we talking about? Hey, I'm a plumber. Joey, my son's a plumber. He plums too. Capiche, rub a chicken. What do you got? Yeah, it's what you do after your foot is in the door.
是的，这太，我是说，这是一个新概念。我是说，我们他妈的在谈论什么？嘿，我是个水管工。乔伊，我儿子是个水管工。他也做管道。Capiche，揉只鸡。你有什么？是的，这是你在脚进门后做的事情。
Like, you know, I mean, if you can stay in there, that's like, then you got something, but nobody's going to apologize for having the door jar. They're going to start saying, well, you know what? You're too funny for comedy. It's unfair. All the funny people are taking over comedy and that's not fair. You're not leaving any room for the unfunny people. Yeah, you're not leaving room for the unfunny people to be in comedy.
就像，你知道，我是说，如果你能待在那里，那就像，然后你就有了东西，但没有人会因为门开着而道歉。他们会开始说，嗯，你知道吗？你对喜剧来说太搞笑了。这不公平。所有有趣的人都在接管喜剧，这不公平。你没有给不好笑的人留下任何空间。是的，你没有给不好笑的人留下空间在喜剧中。
The AI can write songs. It could write a screenplay. Can the AI be funny? We actually, for The Weird Place. Yesterday. By the way, it can. I was actually literally this morning just screwing around with chat. GPT.
AI可以写歌。它可以写剧本。AI能有趣吗？我们实际上，为了《奇怪的地方》。昨天。顺便说一句，它可以。我实际上今天早上就在摆弄聊天。GPT。
GPT. Yeah, that's like incredible. Unbelievable. Unbelievable. That's the next crazy thing. Yeah, but is it funny? Yeah, it actually is. I said, I said, I said, write a thank you note for my friend's party last night.
GPT。是的，那就像令人难以置信。难以置信。难以置信。那是下一个疯狂的事情。是的，但它有趣吗？是的，它实际上是。我说，我说，我说，为我朋友昨晚的派对写一张感谢卡。
And they wrote it out and said, now make it a little bit funny and make it about movies. And it was making this jokes about, well, the food should probably only deserve a nomination, but certainly not a win. And I mean, it was just like in a second. It's amazing. Make fun of a president and George Bush senior. What if it came out? Not got to do it.
他们把它写出来说，现在把它弄得有趣一点，还要和电影有关。于是就有了关于这些笑话，嗯，食物可能只配得到提名，但肯定不配获奖。我的意思是，这简直是一瞬间的事。太神奇了。拿总统和老布什开玩笑。如果它发布了会怎样？不用管它。
An appropriate laugh because he was kind of a robot too. Dana, you need to sue AI. Yeah, no, it sends you. And you're going to ask, but in a weird twist, you're going to say AI, write up a lawsuit against yourself. Well, the weird place is like a very loose takeoff on the Twilight Zone where it's anthology, Twilight Zone. We had one.
一阵恰如其分的笑声，因为他也有点像个机器人。达纳，你需要起诉人工智能。是的，不，它会发给你。你会问，但在一个奇怪的转折中，你会说人工智能，写一份针对你自己的诉讼。嗯，这个奇怪的地方就像是对《阴阳魔界》的一个非常松散的模仿，它是选集，阴阳魔界。我们有一个。
We didn't record where it was the, the J 1000. So it was a robot, an AI robot of Jay Leno. And he's like, yeah, okay, let's go out there. I'm doing a set. And his handler, his computer guy goes, kill him tonight. So he actually ends up killing the audience. He actually, he stands trial. Yeah, you know, I'm, you know, I'm, he said to kill him.
我们没有录制那个，那是J 1000。所以它是一个机器人，一个杰·雷诺的人工智能机器人。他说，好吧，让我们出去吧。我正在表演。他的操纵者，他的电脑专家说，今晚干掉他们。所以他实际上最终杀死了观众。他实际上，他接受了审判。是的，你知道，我，你知道，我，他说要干掉他们。
So I'm dead. My compassion chip was, was that defunct, you know, I got to get changed out. I didn't have any empathy. So I just took them all out, you know, so that's a programming error. It's a, yeah, it was a whole futuristic thing, but that's, that's where we're all going. That is hysterical. We, we, we, you never answered the first, we'll end with this cause the, you never answered the first question, which was how do you,
所以我死了。我的同情心芯片，那是坏了，你知道，我得换掉它。我没有任何同理心。所以我把他们都干掉了，你知道，所以那是一个编程错误。这是一个，是的，这是一个完全的未来主义的东西，但这就是我们所有人要去的地方。这太搞笑了。我们，我们，我们，你从来没有回答第一个，我们以这个结束，因为，你从来没有回答第一个问题，那就是你是怎么，
how, why are you and Bennett are one of our producers houses? Why are you sitting in his house? I'll give these guys. I think I know why. Can I just say the first part is we tried to have you on the show a while ago and we had a technical difficulty. Dana was the guest that we had who at the last minute, we had to bail. But you do a podcast. This was, I'd gotten a new laptop and I, I have a technical thing I do with,
怎么，为什么你和贝内特是我们的一位制片人的房子？你为什么坐在他的房子里？我会给这些人。我想我知道为什么。我能先说第一部分吗？我们很久以前就想让你上节目，但我们遇到了技术困难。达纳是我们当时邀请的嘉宾，最后一刻，我们不得不放弃。但你做了一个播客。这是，我买了一台新笔记本电脑，我，我做了一个技术上的事情，
with fly or we call it the wall. Do you guys ever call it smart? Yeah, we're going, we got a smart coming up. But anyway, so we went through the torturous thing and they, the patients of the guy, during the whole pandemic. Okay. Let's see a red dot on the left. It should be blinking.
用飞，或者我们称之为墙。你们有没有叫它智能？是的，我们要，我们有一个智能即将到来。但无论如何，所以我们经历了那个折磨人的事情，他们，那个家伙的耐心，在整个大流行期间。好吧。让我们看看左边的一个红点。它应该在闪烁。
Yeah. Okay. What do you see? I see a blank screen. All right. Let's refresh out of that. Do you see settings? You see the wheel for settings.
是的。好的。你看到了什么？我看到一个空白屏幕。好吧。让我们刷新一下。你看到设置了吗？你看到设置的轮子了吗？
It's been the biggest part of our lives. And so they did that with me for 45 minutes. And I told him it was like a movie. It was like, ha, ha, ha, we'll get him on. And then it was like, okay, let's, let's, I was like Apollo 13. Let's, let's see what's going on here. We're going to get it. Don't worry.
这是我们生活中最大的一部分。所以他们和我一起做了45分钟。我告诉他这就像一部电影。就像，哈哈，我们会让他上节目的。然后就像，好吧，让我们，让我们，我当时就像阿波罗13号。让我们，让我们看看这里发生了什么。我们会搞定的。别担心。
Press that, do this. I did it around and round and round. The robot said, no, can't do it. And then there was despair and sadness and nervousness toward the end. That's why I said, I'll come over. I lived near here. I said, I'll just come to his house. No way.
按那个，做这个。我绕啊绕啊绕。机器人说，不，做不到。然后最后出现了绝望、悲伤和紧张。这就是为什么我说，我会过去。我住在这附近。我说，我直接去他家。没门。
I mean, you came over to Bennett's house to do this. I know. You are such a love. It was very close by. I could have practically walked. How about that? But you didn't. We'll be right back.
我的意思是，你来到贝内特的家做这个。我知道。你真是个可爱的人。离得很近。我几乎可以走过来。怎么样？但你没有。我们马上回来。
Anyway, so I should say you guys have been so, so nice to me. That's what Paul said. Thanks for all the compliments, which I think he said to you guys. Cause you can't help but gush a little bit with Paul McCartney. Well, that's how we feel about you, man. Honestly. That's right. You have been such a hilarious dude for so long.
总之，我应该说你们对我太好了。保罗就是这么说的。谢谢所有的赞美，我想他是对你们说的。因为你忍不住要对保罗·麦卡特尼滔滔不绝。嗯，我们对你也是这种感觉，伙计。老实说。没错。你一直是一个如此搞笑的家伙。
I've been such a massive fan and admirer. I never knew this. I would have felt so good all these years. I feel like I've bitten off your shit so many times. I feel like I've made people laugh because of you. Yeah. And I just honestly, it's such an honor to. You guys are, you're a universe.
我一直是一个巨大的粉丝和崇拜者。我从来不知道这一点。这些年来我会感觉很好。我觉得我抄袭了你很多次。我觉得因为你，我让人们笑了。是的。我老实说，这真是一种荣幸。你们是，你们是一个宇宙。
You're a, you know, the smart list guys has become a meme. What does the smart list guys do? Where are the smart list guys going? Well, with you and spade, by the way, I texted spade the other day about something and, and, and he didn't text me back. He just sent me a voice note back. I'm like, motherfucker, take the time to write it out.
你们是，你知道，智能列表家伙已经成为一个模因。智能列表家伙做什么？智能列表家伙要去哪里？嗯，顺便说一句，和你还有斯佩德，我前几天给斯佩德发短信关于某件事，而且，而且，他没有回我短信。他只是给我发回了一条语音笔记。我当时想，混蛋，花点时间把它写出来。
That's all he does is the walkie talkie thing. Hey, buddy. Yeah. I was like, oh, cause you can't type that. You know, no space, space, the great, I'm having fun doing it, but this has been a blast.
他做的就是那个对讲机的东西。嘿，伙计。是的。我当时想，哦，因为你不能打字，你知道，没有空格，空格，伟大的，我做得很开心，但这真是一次爆炸。
I know it's hard. I know what it is to wrap it up and like, do we go longer? I know where you guys are at right now. No. So all we have to go along with people that aren't any good. You've given a, this might be a two-parter. What are we going to do? Finish with Dennis Miller.
我知道这很难。我知道结束它是什么感觉，比如，我们要延长吗？我知道你们现在在哪里。不。所以我们必须和那些不好的人一起延长。你给了一个，这可能是一个两部分。我们要怎么办？和丹尼斯·米勒结束。
Christ sakes. Okay. What are these cats? What are they doing? Tucking into a microphone. It's called smart less. Okay. That's an app title from what I've heard over here.
天哪。好吧。这些猫是什么？他们在做什么？对着麦克风说话。它叫智能列表。好吧。那是从我在这里听到的一个应用程序标题。
All right. You got the guy in the middle with the fluffy hair. So thick. It looks like a hair piece. The perennial 10 year old on the right side of my screen. Baseball camps for everybody. Okay. Anybody wear a suit.
好吧。你中间那个头发蓬松的家伙。太厚了。看起来像个假发。我屏幕右侧那个常年的10岁小孩。每个人的棒球训练营。好吧。有人穿西装。
Okay. I like it. Dennis. Just before I let you go. Did you not used to do Dennis to him on update? Oh yeah. Yeah. That's what I regularly used to go on and do.
好吧。我喜欢它。丹尼斯。在我让你走之前。你以前不是在更新中做丹尼斯吗？哦，是的。是的。那是我经常去做的事情。
I go up on it and have the wig and do it. I love his rhythm. I can't. It's the best. I give me a, give me a topic and I'll do Dennis is talking about any time. A podcast and there's too many of them. Yeah.
我上去戴上假发做那个。我喜欢他的节奏。我不能。这是最好的。给我一个，给我一个话题，我随时都会做丹尼斯谈话。一个播客，而且太多了。是的。
Podcast. Okay. What are we up to? 109 million now. Okay. Every kid in the basement with a microphone and a cheap laptop can just start yapping out there looking at the, looking at those counts.
播客。好吧。我们现在有多少了？现在1.09亿了。好吧。地下室里每个拿着麦克风和廉价笔记本电脑的孩子都可以开始在那儿喋喋不休地看着，看着那些数字。
What's he got? Three 29 people listening to this problem. All right. Okay. What happened to Edward R. Murrow? One guy with talent with a mic. I got six million people without a clue. Okay.
他有多少？329个人在听这个问题。好吧。好吧。爱德华·R·默罗怎么了？一个有才华的人拿着麦克风。我有六百万人毫无头绪。好吧。
I haven't seen this much dysfunction since the dysfunctional convention in Utah. All right. It doesn't even have to make sense. It's so good. It's so good. Well, you're great. You're great.
我没见过这么多的功能障碍，自从犹他州的功能障碍大会以来。好吧。它甚至不需要有意义。太好了。太好了。嗯，你很棒。你很棒。
That's crazy that you can do that. God, thank you so much for coming on and entertaining us. You're such a consumer. All right. Well, okay. I'll say this, this was because it'll never happen. We'll all have dinner at Koi with spade. And we'll blow people's minds.
你能做到这一点真是太疯狂了。上帝，非常感谢你来招待我们。你真是个消费者。好吧。好吧，我会说这个，这是因为这永远不会发生。我们都会和斯佩德在Koi吃晚饭。我们会让人们大吃一惊。
Let's do it. Let's do it. I'll just leave you with this. I use George Bush senior for anxiety. I make lists with him and this is not a joke. Coming over here. Went to the producer's house. Producer Bennett.
让我们做吧。让我们做吧。我只想留给你这个。我用老布什来缓解焦虑。我和他列清单，这不是开玩笑。来到这里。去了制片人的房子。制片人贝内特。
Will. Will. Sean over there. Jason. Talent. Full modicum. Every area. Game shows, movies, television.
威尔。威尔。肖恩在那边。杰森。才华。充分的少量。每个领域。游戏节目，电影，电视。
Sit comms. American treasures. Coming at ya. Talking over. Not a subject. Long rambles. Number one. Oh, so good.
情景喜剧。美国宝藏。向你走来。谈论。不是一个主题。长篇大论。第一名。哦，太好了。
That is unbelievable. Calm me. Calm me down. Calm now. All right. I love you, Dana Carvey. I love you, Dana Carvey. I love you, Dana Carvey.
那真是令人难以置信。让我冷静。让我冷静。冷静现在。好吧。我爱你，达纳·卡维。我爱你，达纳·卡维。我爱你，达纳·卡维。
Bye, Dana. Bye. Well, that could be all time. All time. Could be all time. What a hilarious dude. Yeah. And just like this.
再见，达纳。再见。嗯，那可能是史上最好的。史上最好的。可能是史上最好的。真是个搞笑的家伙。是的。就像这样。
Like this. Like this. Like what's the subject? Give me a thing. Give me a suggestion. Like in a constant, you know, unbelievable talent. And like, and again, you can't fake that. He's back.
像这样。像这样。像主题是什么？给我一个东西。给我一个建议。就像在一个持续的，你知道，令人难以置信的才华。而且，再一次，你不能伪造那个。他回来了。
He keeps leaving the room and coming back. You can't. You can't. You know, it's what we were talking about. You can't fake it, right? It's genuine. And it's just pure. And I don't think I, I wasn't that energetic when I was 12.
他一直在离开房间又回来。你不能。你不能。你知道，这就是我们正在谈论的。你不能伪造它，对吧？它是真实的。而且它只是纯粹的。我不认为我，我12岁的时候没有那么精力充沛。
I was going to ask him that. He's got like these sketch comedy people like Marty Short or him or whoever it is. They have so much energy all the time. It's great engines. Like they just all, they can run. But you know what I thought was interesting about him was the, I was going to ask about this is that when he did all those
我本来要问他那个。他有像马蒂·肖特或者他或者无论谁那样的素描喜剧演员。他们一直有那么多的精力。是伟大的引擎。就像他们都，他们可以跑。但你知道我认为关于他有趣的是，我本来要问这个，就是当他做所有那些
roles as a kid, you know, as when he was younger and he was an actor first and then he was in sketch comedy. And I bet you that's why he was such a star in comedy. He never done sketch comedy. He never done sketch comedy before. Yeah. I know, but he was an actor. He's one of the, he's one of the all time great sketch comics.
角色作为孩子，你知道，当他年轻的时候，他首先是一个演员，然后他从事素描喜剧。我敢打赌这就是为什么他在喜剧中是一个明星。他从来没有做过素描喜剧。他以前从来没有做过素描喜剧。是的。我知道，但他是一个演员。他是史上最伟大的素描喜剧演员之一。
Yeah. Incredible. I love him. I love that idea. Like, yeah, you want to bring up all this stuff. And he was talking about like with McCartney, like, can I bring up the Beatles and can I bring up the songs? And with a guy like him, like, can I, I want to bring up church
是的。不可思议。我爱他。我喜欢那个想法。比如，是的，你想提出所有这些东西。他在谈论像麦卡特尼，比如，我可以提出披头士乐队吗，我可以提出歌曲吗？对于像他这样的人，比如，我可以，我想提出教堂
and talk about all the great things and be like, talking to Sean and not bringing up Candy Crush. You know what I mean? Yeah. The things you're good at. Right. Exactly. You're going to talk that you're known for.
并谈论所有伟大的事情，就像和肖恩交谈而不提出糖果粉碎。你知道我的意思吗？是的。你擅长的事情。对。完全正确。你要谈论你出名的事情。
Yeah. You're going to bring up Skittles and Candy Crush. I have to believe that a show like the Dana Carvey show would work today because there are stations that would, you know, you throw it on HBO today or Netflix today. And you know, I, why not? We're on broadcast. You'd think that broadcast would want something like that.
是的。你要提出彩虹糖和糖果粉碎。我必须相信像达纳·卡维秀这样的节目今天会奏效，因为有电视台会，你知道，你今天把它放在HBO或Netflix上。而且你知道，我，为什么不呢？我们在广播。你会认为广播会想要那样的东西。
No, but they have, as you said, they've tried that variety show thing. Maya had her own, right? I think it was the latest one. With Marty. With Marty. Yeah. Over at NBC.
不，但他们有，正如你所说，他们尝试过那种综艺节目。玛雅有她自己的，对吧？我想那是最新的一个。和马蒂一起。和马蒂一起。是的。在NBC。
Right. It's just, I don't know why they don't take, why SNL is the only one that has sustained is a tribute to Lauren certainly, but I could do with a couple of more. I can't believe he has all this energy at his age after having gone through, which you don't know about Jason. You didn't, you didn't remember that he had,
对。我只是不知道为什么他们不采取，为什么SNL是唯一一个持续下来的，这是对劳伦的致敬，当然，但我可以再多做几个。我不敢相信他在这个年纪还有这么多精力，在经历了之后，你不知道关于杰森。你没有，你没有记住他有，
what kind of surgery on his heart? It's a bypass surgery. What kind of surgery was that? It was a bypass surgery. It was a bypass surgery. It was a bypass surgery. Bye Pat. Bye.
他的心脏做了什么样的手术？这是搭桥手术。那是什么样的手术？这是搭桥手术。这是搭桥手术。这是搭桥手术。再见帕特。再见。
Wow Sean. Bye. Very good. Sounds good. That was good. Smart. What? Smart.
哇肖恩。再见。非常好。听起来不错。那很好。聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。什么？Smartless是100%有机的，由
What? Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart. What? Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by
贝内特烧烤，迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿姆贾斯手工制作。聪明。大。我们的下一集将在一个星期内发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以听，在亚马逊音乐上提前听，或者通过订阅或Wondery应用程序提前且无广告地听。
Bennett BBQ, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarth. Smart. Large. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to or the Wondery app.
越来越多的熊正在冒险进入阿拉斯加海恩斯镇寻找食物，让居民感到紧张。然后，每个人最担心的恐惧变成了现实。三名经验丰富的野外滑雪者在不知情的情况下滑过一个巢穴，惊醒了一只母熊和她的幼崽。她发动了攻击，其中一名男子在朋友绝望地等待救援时为生命而战。无论你在哪里获取播客，请关注Against the Odds。你可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery应用程序上无广告收听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
More and more bears are venturing into the town of Haines, Alaska in search of food, putting residents on edge. Then, everyone's worst fears are realized. Three experienced backcountry skiers unknowingly ski over a den and awaken a mother bear and her cub. She attacks, and one of the men is left fighting for his life while his friends desperately wait for help to arrive. Follow against the odds wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
越来越多的熊为了寻找食物闯入阿拉斯加州海恩斯镇，让当地居民感到不安。随后，人们最担心的事情发生了。三名经验丰富的野外滑雪者在不知情的情况下滑过了一个熊窝，惊醒了一只母熊和它的幼崽。母熊发起了攻击，其中一名男子在生死边缘挣扎，而他的朋友们则在绝望中等待救援。无论你在哪里收听播客，都可以关注《Against the Odds》。你可以在Amazon Music或Wondery应用程序上收听无广告版本。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。